Und das geht so, das ist mich grad nix.
Was soll, was soll am 1.1. um 9 Uhr schon groß gehen?
Oh, recommended channels, Amorant, Pool Streams, ne was wird recommended?
Also was wird da teilweise für channels empfohlen werden?
Hab ich noch nie reingeguckt, noch hab ich das großartig vor, aber gut.
Wenn Twitch das meint, dass ich das gucken soll.
Dann guck ich es trotzdem nicht, aber.
Tja, ich weiß nicht wie lange ich jetzt on bin, ich bin übelst müde.
Heute Nacht kannst du dich ja nicht wirklich pennen.
Also bei dir war es bestimmt nicht, noch schon, aber nicht gut, ja, also fest, fest und irgendwie
so hab ich gut geschlafen, hab ich netz, aber es war jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig schlimm
oder so.
Man hat das, man hat das schon ausgehalten.
Moin, naja ich hoffe heute passt der Sound wieder halbwegs, ich hab jetzt die ganzen
OBS Settings kopiert.
Und test, test, na doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, ich glaub jetzt alles gut.
Ich hab jetzt die ganzen OBS Sachen kopiert und sowohl Lautstärke als auch Bilder und
Zeug, das sollte eigentlich alles passen, aber man weiß ja nie was Windows, also bei
Settings und Windows und Sachen, also generell muss ich sagen, also Windows 11, ganz im Ernst,
ich hab jetzt, also ich verwende das jetzt ja seit zwei Wochen ungefähr und ja, es hat
gewisse Vorteile, die Vorteile sind aber hauptsächlich, weil Microsoft sagt, diese Sachen gibt es
halt einfach nicht mehr für Windows 10, also nicht notwendigerweise und nicht weil sie
es besser gemacht haben, sondern einfach weil sie es bei den alten explizit auslassen.
Klingt anders, ich muss mir das mal kurz anhören.
Es sollte mehr oder weniger gleich, also gut es kann sein, dass weil heute, weil ich jetzt,
mal kurz meinen eigenen, mal kurz meinen eigenen Stream anhören.
Mal kurz meinen eigenen Stream aufmachen und gucken, wie sich das anhört, oh Gott, ja,
jetzt muss ich mir, jetzt muss ich mir all die Werbung von meinem eigenen Kram angucken,
ja wunderbar, der Original hat all die Preise, so lass mal kurz gucken, der Original hat
all die Preise, naja lass mal kurz gucken, passt eigentlich, ist eigentlich ok, ja wahrscheinlich
hört sich einfach an, weil es heute erster erster ist, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen,
ja also Windows 11 Leute, ohne Scheiß, es hat ja gewisse Vorteile, einfach weil Windows
10 manche Sachen nicht bekommt, wie zum Beispiel, ich weiß gar nicht wie man sich das jetzt
anzeigen lässt, wie lässt man sich hier alle, logical process los, ja, also wie zum Beispiel,
dass man ordentlich die ganzen efficiency cores in dem 13900k verwenden kann, also ich
meine, der sagt ja nur, es sind 31 CPUs, das stimmt ja gar nicht, es sind nicht 31 CPUs,
es sind 8 Kerne und nochmal, keine Ahnung, 12 oder, nochmal 8, nochmal 8, 8 normale
Kerne, 8 efficiency, nee 16 efficiency cores und 8, ach was weiß ich aus dem Kopf, ich
hab keine Ahnung was in meiner CPU drin ist, genau, zumindest der task scheduler, also
dass die efficiency cores und das ganze Zeug ordentlich verwendet werden, das gibt es nur
unter Windows 11, das gibt es nicht unter Windows 10, das ist auch so der eine Punkt,
warum ich Windows 11 jetzt genommen habe anstatt Windows 10, so, aber Windows 11 hat so viele
andere Dinge, die mir wirklich auf den Keks gehen und ich hab den Eindruck, dass Windows
11 so ein Versuch von Microsoft ist, wie sehr man die Leute gängeln kann und wie viel die
noch mitmachen, so für Windows 12 dann oder sowas, anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären,
es sind so viele Sachen, es fängt ja schon an, dass es jetzt richtig dreckreich ist,
das Ding überhaupt zu installieren, ohne lokalen Account, ich will mich nicht mit einem Microsoft
Account einloggen müssen, dass ich mein lokales Windows, warum, das will ich nicht, die sollen
mir nicht auf den Sack gehen, du kannst viele Software auch gar nicht gescheit umziehen,
ist mir aufgefallen, ich hab zum Beispiel die Profile kopiert, für Chrome, Chromium,
Firefox, OBS, OBS und Firefox waren zu erwarten, überhaupt keine Probleme, Profile kopiert
geht 1 zu 1, gar kein Problem, Chrom kopiert geht nur zur Hälfte, Chromium auch geht nur
zur Hälfte, Extensions kommen nicht mit, Extension Settings kommen nicht mit, manche
normalen Settings kommen nicht mit, Sessions gehen verloren, du musst dich überall neu
einloggen, Firefox gar kein Problem, Profile rüber geschoben geht, Chrome kann es wieder
vergessen, warum, naja ganz klar, weil die Typen wollen, dass man hier ihren komischen
Scheiß Google Sync Crap verwendet, also es ist sehr viel nerviges Zeug an vielen Stellen
und dann geht es, das geht ja noch weiter, dass du jetzt unter Windows 11 immer so hier
machen musst, guck, seht ihr das, ich kann nicht einfach, guck mal, ich hab so viel Platz
hier unten, seht ihr das, so viel Platz und ich muss jetzt so machen, damit ich mein richtiges
Chrome Fenster finde und manchmal geht das gar nicht, manchmal geht die Startleiste nicht
in Vordergründen, es ist hinter irgendeinem Fenster, es ist unglaublich schlecht gemacht,
gibt es kein Plugin für die Taskleiste, das Ding unterstützt doch keine Plugins, was es
gibt ist, es gibt so ein Replacement, was die Windows 11 Taskleiste durch die Windows
10 Taskleiste replacet, aber das ist doch auch alles nur temporäres rumgefrickelt, ich mein,
ihr dürft nicht vergessen, es ging bis vor ganz, bis vor kurzer Zeit, ach es geht immer
noch nicht, ok, ok, ok, also man konnte bis vor noch nicht, ich mach den Gramm hier mal
kurz zu, man konnte vor noch nicht all zu langer Zeit keine Sachen von der Taskleiste
und auf die Task, na gut, das geht nicht, guck, also man kann keine Sachen mehr von und in
die Taskleiste gescheit ziehen, ok, dass das funktioniert, ok, also es ist sehr weirdchampig
gemacht alles, aber immerhin wisst ihr was, dass es ein mega geiles neues Feature gibt,
richtig, richtig massiv neues Feature, ihr habt es eben im Stream schon gesehen, guck
mal, man kann den Task Manager jetzt über die Taskleiste wieder aufmachen, krass oder,
richtig krasses Zeug, oh ich hab das Memboard nicht rüber kopiert Leute, ich hab vergessen
das Memboard rüber zu kopieren, oder was geht mir denn mit der Musik jetzt ab, übertreib
halt, das gab es nicht, korrekt, du konntest bis zur letzten Windows Version nicht rechts
klicken und sagen Task Manager, das ist erst seit 2 Wochen oder so möglich wieder, kacke,
ja, ist wirklich so, ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht, ich hab vergessen das Memboard
rüber zu kopieren, ja gut, das bekomme ich jetzt nicht hin, gescheit, aus dem USB Stick
holen oder so, ja, ich hab in den letzten Tagen viele deiner alten Videos über Ausbildung
und Beruf geguckt, ja ich hab ja auch neuere, ich hab ja nicht nur die ganz alten Dinge,
was ich mich gefragt habe ist, ob du manchmal bereust nicht Informatik, ne gar nicht, warum
sollte ich das bereuen, ne, also denkst du aus irgendeinem speziellen Grund, dass das
der Fall sein könnte, du kannst mich auch mal konkret fragen, aber nicht, mir fällt
jetzt nichts ein, dass ich das bereut hätte oder bereuen würde, man kann es einfach abgesehen,
ich bin viel zu faul um noch was zu studieren, also ich bin zu faul um jetzt was zu studieren,
das auf jeden Fall und ich wäre auch deutlich zu faul gewesen, damals war es zu studieren,
ja und mir ist aufgefallen, Windows bringt jetzt das neue Terminal mit, aber nicht WinGet,
ah wie, doch, wait a minute, ach doch, ok, ok, dann hab ich nichts gesagt, William ja
eigentlich hat geguckt, da gab es kein WinGet, ja, also Windows 11 ist echt so ein Ding,
neuer PC, ja, ne aber ohne Scheiß, Windows 11 ist echt so ein Ding, das hätte die Welt
nicht gebraucht, das einzige und Microsoft selbst sieht es ja ähnlich, guckt euch mal
diesen ganzen Schrott an, Alter, was ist das hier, Whatsapp, Unpin, Spotify, Unpin, Disney
Plus, Unpin, Xbox, Unpin, Clipchamp, ok, es hat einen guten Namen, aber trotzdem, Unpin,
Prime Video, Unpin, TikTok, Unpin, Instagram, Unpin, Messenger, Unpin, ok, der Kalkulator
darf da bleiben, Alarm und Clocks, brauch ich nicht, Tips, Unpin, Office, Unpin, ich hab
keine Ahnung, Microsoft Store, Doppelt Unpin, Mail, Unpin, Edge, Unpin, nice, sehr gut,
schon mal toll, dass das alles voll ist, Solidär, Casual, Unpin, Fotos, Unpin, Kalender, ja
vielleicht irgendwann mal, keine Ahnung, oh man, es ist auch so viel Schrott am Start,
guckt euch das an, News, Unpin, ne, keine Ahnung, ja, bleibt ihr erspart, ja, ganze Schrott
da, aber trotzdem, Microsoft selbst, ja, weiß ja im Endeffekt auch, dass es irgendwie, außer
ein bisschen Optik, und selbst das ist, kann man diskutieren, ja, nicht wirklich was zu
bieten hat, weil erinnert ihr euch noch an diese Windows 11 Präsentation, im Prinzip
haben die zwei Sachen gemacht, die haben permanent erzählt, wie beautiful das neue Windows ist,
haben irgendwelche Widgets gezeigt, wo ich mich frage, wer verwendet irgendwelche komischen
Widgets, dieser Widget Crap war unter Windows 8 schon Müll, niemand will irgendwelche komischen
Widgets, ich weiß gar nicht wie ich die überhaupt aufmache hier irgendwie, ach übrigens noch
was was abgeschafft wurde, passt mal auf, ich mache ja immer gerne VMWare auf, auf
den zweiten Bildschirm, ich glaube ich habe meine VMs auch nicht umgezogen, ne, so, und
dann switch ich rüber, guckt mal, es gibt keine Desktop Switch Animation mehr, die hat
sich Microsoft geschenkt, früher gab es auch eine Desktop Switch Animation, die tatsächlich
ganz praktisch war, weil, wundert mich, dass da bei Microsoft keiner dran gedacht hat,
jetzt passt mal auf, tja, auf welchem, wenn ihr mal die Eigens hier unten nicht sehen
würdet, auf welchem Desktop bin ich Leute, switche ich den Desktop, tja, man sieht es
nicht mehr, weil es keine, auch noch so kleine Desktop Switch Animation gibt, Desktop Switch
Animation wurde einfach entfernt, guck ich switche Desktop und du siehst es überhaupt
nicht, dass ich Desktop switche, und gerade wenn du vielleicht jetzt nicht unten auf
die Eigens guckst oder andere Sachen gestartet hast, hast du halt gelitten, siehst du nicht,
es ist teilweise total undurchdacht, ja, also Microsoft hat ja auch die ganze Zeit nur erzählt
in ihrer Windows presentation, dass es so beautiful ist und dass es so emotional ist, wo ich mir
gedacht habe, also wenn Windows bei mir emotional ist, dann eigentlich nur weil mich irgendwas
abfuckt und nicht weil ich irgendwie mit Windows jetzt so die geilen Erinnerungen verbinde,
eher damit, was ich damals gemacht habe, ja, nicht mit Windows selbst, selbst an Windows
98, ich denke an die Zeit natürlich gerne zurück, wo ich damals so richtig angefangen
habe mit Games und Half Life rausgekommen ist und sowas, aber so dass ich sagen würde,
alter Windows 98 war das geilste Ever, im Leben nicht, keine Ahnung, die haben wie gesagt
diese zwei Sachen hat Microsoft erzählt, die haben die ganze Zeit erzählt, es ist super
beautiful und sie haben sie auch voll emotional gemacht und wo ich mir echt, wo ich mir echt
oft an den Kopf gegriffen habe ist, wo die eine in der Präsentation erzählt hat, oh,
sie erinnert sich so gern an altes Windows zurück, als sie mit ihrem Vater noch vorm
PC gesessen hat und so, das war so failanstellt, ich mein gut, sie konnten ja auch nichts zeigen,
was hätten sie zeigen sollen, es gibt jetzt eine Taskleiste, wo du nicht mal den Taskmanager
aufmachen kannst oder das, ach nee Moment nicht, Notepad hat Widgets, der Explorer hat
jetzt Tabs und komische neue Icons und sowas, aber unter der Haube ist es halt immer noch
der alte Kackexplorer, ja, wobei, der geht und was sie auch noch haben ist jetzt in der
hinter 85 Menüs versteckt, stellt euch mal vor Leute, ich möchte das Icon hiervon ändern,
tja, das gibt's gar nicht mehr oder was, ich mein guckt mal, wisst ihr was das für
bescheuertes ist, also man kann doch nicht mal gescheite Icons ändern anscheinend, also
ist wirklich echt richtig hängen geblieben, Tabs ist tatsächlich, das war wohl auch das
einzige Sinnvolle, ich mein man muss sagen, hier guck mal, beispielsweise die neue Setting
App, die ist schon besser gemacht als die alte Settings App, aber das war auch wirklich
keine Kunst, aber nicht zu vergessen Leute, wer gedacht hat, das Control Panel ist jetzt
weg, nein, nein, nein, nein, manche Sachen wie gescheite Energie, also wenn ihr zum Beispiel
eure Idle Time für Festplatte und sowas gescheit einstellen wollt und Shutdown und
Gesöns ausschalten wollt gescheit, dann müsst ihr weiterhin ins Control Panel in
den Windows 2000 Dialog, wo schaltet man diesen komischen, wo kann man das nochmal ausschalten
mit Hibernate beim Shutdown, ich glaub das hab ich ausgeschaltet, aber ich wollt jetzt
mal nachgucken, ich weiß nicht mehr wo es ist, Slideshow, naja alles klar, ich bin mir
da auch nicht sicher, ich mein bei vielen Sachen kannst du dich drüber streiten, wie
es jetzt besser ist, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat,
ja es ist besser, dass man jetzt alles in Icons kopiert hat in der Taskleiste, ich weiß
nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, ja Reckeredit gibt
es auch noch, ja, hast du beim Arctic Cooler eine Lüfter Kurve eingestellt, kann man die
Lüfter einstellen und die Pumpe immer auf 100% lassen, also nachdem du nur einen Anschluss
hast für dieses gesamte Ding, vermute ich, dass das nicht geht, also du hast ja nur einen
so PWM 4-Pin-Connector, glaub ich zumindest, ich hab's ja im Stream zusammengebaut, also
das geht nicht, also ja ich hab ne Lüfter Kurve eingestellt, aber die Fortlüfter, ich
kann euch das auch zeigen hier irgendwo, und das hier, naja ich machs hier lieber nicht
auf, wer weiß ob es dann irgendwelche Settings kaputt macht, keine Ahnung, äh Leute ist
das Display jetzt schwarz bei euch, nee jetzt gehts wieder, ja also ja ich hab die
Standard Signend Lüfter Kurve eingestellt, aber nix spezielles sonst, Netzwerk Settings
sind auch äußerst wir, was ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde, übrigens was auch witzig
ist, das hier wird kopiert angezeigt, aber es sind zwei unterschiedliche Buttons, was
ich tatsächlich ganz gut finde ist der neue Mixer, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche, aber
ich find's tatsächlich von oben nach unten angeordnet besser, du hast einfach mehr Platz
hier für die Sachen, das ist schon ok, die Mikrofon Lautstärke, das geht nicht etwa
da drüber, wenn du hier aufs Mikrofon drückst, also ich mein wer möchte auch schon die Lautstärke
einstellen, wenn er aufs Mikrofon drückt, logischerweise möchte ich Privacy und Security
für mein Mikrofon einstellen, wenn ich aufs Mikrofon klicke, ist ja logisch, ich hab
vergessen wo es geht, tja Leute wie stellt man die Lautstärke vom Mikrofon ein, da fängt
schon an, ich hab's gestern gefunden irgendwo, Sound Settings vielleicht, Input, ahja, ne
ne ne, also Leute wer denkt, dass er aufs Mikrofon klicken kann um die Mikrofon Lautstärke
einzustellen, nicht bei Microsoft, so geht das nicht, du musst hier ne super ruckelige
Anzeige anschauen, du musst auf den Lautsprecher klicken, rechts und dann auf Sound Settings
und dann runter zur Input, alles klar, logisch, obviously, ja muss man nicht verstehen, naja
gibt's so ein paar Sachen wo ich mir denke, was, warum, warum ist das da, ja ich muss
echt, ich muss echt mein Memboard umziehen, aber kann ich jetzt nicht gescheit machen,
weil ich nicht, weil doch kann ich, kann ich machen, wartet mal, New Ordner, wartet mal,
Kecke, KeckW, wie shared man jetzt hier was, Properties, Sharing, Share, Stream, keine
Ahnung ob ich das so richtig mache, Share, okay jetzt muss ich irgendwas eintippen, KeckW,
ja, okay und jetzt kann ich da was drauf kopieren, Moment, das probieren wir jetzt aus, ich weiß
ja zum Glück die IP von der Kiste aus dem Kopf, Users, Stream, äh
Hä, ich seh den Ordner nicht, ich seh den Ordner nicht, obwohl ich den grad geshared
hab, ist auch geil, lull, aber ich kann wahrscheinlich über die Userfreigabe, so ich schieb mal
kurz, ich schieb mal kurz mein Memboard rüber, dazu muss ich, ah dazu muss ich auf den anderen
Account, das, das brauch ich aber hier Leute, das müssen wir jetzt, das müssen wir jetzt
kurz machen, ich log mich mal kurz um, schauen wir mal, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, bin ich
mal gespannt ob ich das hinkriege hier rüber, das rüber zu kopieren, Stream einloggen,
Stream Account auf der einen Seite einloggen, hier share ein Folder aufmachen, hrq windows
zeug jetzt hier angesagt, Stream, Desktop, CACW, so Memboard, wo liegt das, hier, Memetool,
da ist es doch, copy, ok es kopiert Leute, es kopiert, es kopiert mega langsam, aber
es kopiert, es braucht ne Minute das zu kopieren, ja, das kopiert jetzt, wo ist mein, ah alter,
wo ist mein Desktop hier, da, Shared, was nicht alles gibt, Notepad jetzt schon Tabs,
nee, wäre mir neu das Notepad Tabs, Quatsch, alter, Notepad Tabs, du kannst jetzt, du kannst
jetzt Themes wechseln und sowas, ich mein immerhin ist nicht mehr dieser Schrott hier
am Start, sondern was ordentliches, nehme ich das neue Windows Terminal, seht ihr, selbst
wenn man CMD macht, ich weiß auch nicht was, vctl, Containers mit Forever Workstation,
alles klar, alles klar, so das Memetool ist kopiert, schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert,
kopieren wir das mal auf dem Desktop, weil brauche ich hier, achja, was mir aufgefallen
ist, wenn man Ordner kopiert hat, muss man prinzipiell immer Read Only raus machen, hat
jemand einen Plan warum, I don't know, keine Ahnung, Microsoft, Microsoft Logik, geht eigentlich
der Chat, Leute, geht die Chat Vorschau, schreibt mal einer Test oder so, gucken ob die Chat
Vorschau funktioniert, im Stream sollte eigentlich, geht nicht, natürlich geht doch, Fake News,
okay hier, Memetool, ich hoffe das bin, Alter, das ist ja ein uralt Programm, wie habe ich
das jetzt gestartet, Web Application, hier, warum, warum geht das nicht, warum, ohje, well
you can not be null, ahja, obviously, data protection keys, was, was will, wenn, was
will Windows von mir, was will, hä, was will, Alter, ich will einfach was starten, schein
komplizierter zu sein als angenommen, okay, ich muss mal angucken wie ich das hier starte,
okay, okay, okay, hier muss ich hin, hier muss ich hin, alles klar, ich weiß wie es
geht, also Debug, das ist uralt das Ding, ist wirklich uralt, Web Application 11, so
und jetzt, Properties, start in da, und jetzt sollte es gehen, zack, yes, yes, access, jawoll,
schauen wir mal, gleich, gleich, jetzt gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal ob meine Software
funktioniert und da Windows 11, jetzt hat er eh den besten, hat er eh den besten Namen,
Web Application, Web Application 11, weiß eh jeder Bescheid, ne, welcher Port ist es,
5002, hey Leute, es funktioniert, stellt euch das mal vor, einfach so, okay, okay,
es gibt Zeit, geht ja nicht, einfach so, Mann, Wahnsinn, so, als ob wir den ganzen Kram
noch verschieben, gehen die anderen Sounds noch, Moment, wo, wo ist der KekWee Sound?
Da, okay, funktioniert alles, exellent, wir haben es geschafft, ja das mag sein aber
in der aktuellen Form will das keiner verwenden, davon habt ihr, das ist was ein.NET Framework
4.6 Projekt noch oder so, ja, okay, immerhin, jetzt fühle ich mich nicht mehr so nackig,
jetzt habe ich wieder ein paar Billchen, die ich einplanten kann, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel
kann ich euch auch jetzt jibaden, bisschen Panik auslösen in manche, was ist hier los,
warum schreibt der Chef am 1.1., ist irgendwas kaputt, Produktivsystemausfall, Moment, wie
ist eigentlich die Lautstärke von den, von den Sachen jetzt, das muss ich mal kurz kontrollieren,
ob ich sie laute, wie macht man das jetzt in diesem Volume Mixer, Main Window, alles
klar, da weiß man Bescheid, okay, alles klar, jetzt die Lautstärke, jetzt die Lautstärke,
okay, ja Leute, ich weiß nicht, was wollen wir machen, wollen wir uns ein paar Sachen
auf YouTube angucken, lasst mal, lasst mal schauen, was habe ich hier noch auf, was,
was haben wir hier noch, TikTok, oh, nee, nee, please, please, kein Plus, ach ja, was
sagt er dann hier, what am I self hosting in my Homelab, wir haben doch letzte Woche
von diesem Typ geguckt, wo er uns sein neues Rack gezeigt hat und wo ich schon immer gesagt
habe, was macht er damit eigentlich und heute kriegen wir es anscheinend erzählt, wir werden
uns das nicht 38 Minuten angucken, ich werde einfach drüber skippen, aber ich wette mit
euch, es ist immer noch das gleiche wie vor zwei Jahren, dass er seine wahnsinns Infrastruktur
daheim hat, nur um die Infrastruktur zu betreiben, nicht um wirklich was Sinnvolles zu betreiben,
woran er dann im Endeffekt auch was mit anfangen kann, das, das, das, das, das muss ich mir
jetzt mal anschauen, wir skippen da mal, guckt mal Leute, ich kann noch nicht mal, es ist
so ätzend, ich kann noch nicht mal hier irgendwie schnell jetzt das finden, um die Musik auszumachen,
es ist richtig dumm, es ist einfach richtig dumm, okay laut genug, ja, weil es unsinnig
ist, Dashboard, okay, es geht los mit einem sinnlosen Dashboard, ja, es geht los mit einem
sinnlosen Dashboard, der hat ja fast, eben hat er noch wirklich fast geguckt, wie dieser,
wie heißt der Meme-Opa nochmal, pain, show no pain, ach fuck, find ich jetzt blöd, pain,
ihr wisst was ich meine, meme pain, ja, genau, ihn meine ich, ja, hide the pain, das habe
ich gemeint, genau, das habe ich gemeint, hide the pain, das Ding, das Ding habe ich
auch mal aus Shoke-Zwecken aufgesetzt, ist ganz nützlich, aber ganz im Ernst, der Sinn
von Dashboards erschließt sich mir immer noch nicht, weil, seriously, man kann auch
einfach Browser, man kann auch einfach Browser-Tabs verwenden und nicht Browser-Tabs, Browser-Bookmarks
verwenden und fertig, easy, geht genauso, aber, ja gut, wenn man vielleicht dann vom Tablet
drauf zugreift und irgendwie da ist, ich verstehe, aber, ist wahrscheinlich noch das sinnvollste
in seinem Setup, was ist, was ist Shink, oder, nee, Shlink, oder Shink, oder Shink, das ist
Shink, oder, nee, Shink, was ist Shink, Shink, ein eigener Url-Shortener, okay, das hat natürlich
die Welt gebraucht, okay, wir sehen ja schon hier im Prinzip Wasser betreiben, das ist
nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich viel, was wirklich dafür da ist, um was zu machen, ja, Rancher
ist Infrastruktur, Chunas ist Infrastruktur, okay, es ist nass, das lasse ich nochmal durchgehen,
aber, Infrastruktur, was war Longhorn nochmal, das war der Codename für Windows Vista, glaube
oder Windows XP, aber es ist irgendwas anderes, Cloud Native Distributed Storage, genau, auch
Infrastruktur, auch Infrastruktur, ja, auch Infrastruktur, auch Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur,
Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Monitoring, also Infrastruktur, dreimal Piehole, einer tut's
nicht, Homebridge, okay, okay, okay, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, Infrastruktur, also im Prinzip
ist das 90%, 90% seiner, 95% seiner Sachen sind dazu da, um sich selbst zu verwalten,
also das ist auch irgendwie komisch, wir skippen, wir skippen, wir skippen ein bisschen, genau,
genau, aber so ist es, I host services to host services and to host services, Proxmox,
hat er nicht letztens mal auch was über VMA erzählt, wait a minute, hat er nicht, hat
er nicht irgendwie auch ein paar Kubernetes Cluster und Gedöns, die hat er quasi als
VMA auf Proxmox oder wie oder, ach keine Ahnung, warum genau, okay, Leute, warum, warum, warum
braucht man einen Triple-Node-Virtualisierungscluster daheim, wenn man am Ende gar nichts darauf
betreibt, also ich hab ja kein Problem damit, wenn einer ein Triple-Cluster-Node-Virtualisierungscluster
daheim betreibt, wenn er dann darauf auch VMs betreibt, aber da ist ja nichts drauf,
ich mein, selbst das hier ist jetzt nicht wirklich viel, aber okay, alles klar, alles klar, alles
klar, okay, er hat einen Triple-Node-Proxmox-Cluster, um darauf dann ein Kubernetes-Cluster laufen
zu lassen, alles klar, das ist für HA, also eine Sache, die ich jetzt nach über 15 Jahren
im IT-Business gelernt hab, ist, übertriebenes HA, ohne den Bedarf für HA, sorgt meistens
für mehr Ausfälle als ohne HA, also HA ist High Availability. Wenn ich überlege, wie
viele Probleme wir hatten, rein durch die Existenz von High Availability-Maßnahmen, die dann
letztendlich auch zu Problemen geführt haben, wäre an manchen Stellen keine High Availability
wahrscheinlich besser gewesen, und High Availability, ohne dass man es wirklich braucht, ist meistens
keine gute Idee, also zum Beispiel, wenn man daheim sitzt, hat seine Kiste hinter sich
stehen, will ein paar VMs drauf betreiben, und man steht jetzt vor der Wahl, hey, betreibe
ich da einfach drei VMs drauf und gut ist, hänge eine externe Festplatte dran, mach
ab und zu mal ein paar Backups, und sollte wirklich mal was kaputt gehen, brauch ich
halt mal eine halbe Stunde was zu restoren, oder aber sollte wirklich die komplette Kiste
einen Kurzschluss haben und kaputt gehen, dann brauch ich halt mal drei, vier Tage,
bis ich Ersatzhardware hab, aber ich hab immer noch mal ein Backup, oder, also das versus,
ich baue mir drei Server daheim hin, und mach's super krass kompliziert, sodass ich
mir mindestens am Tag zwei, drei Stunden drum kümmern muss, dass meine Infrastruktur überhaupt
funktioniert, also, es ist meistens, ach ja, und wie viele Probleme bekomme ich dadurch,
das ist eigentlich das, was ich sagen wollte, ganz vergessen, und wie viele Probleme bekomme
ich dadurch, dass ich alles hochverfügbar gemacht habe, also, von Interconnect-Problemen
zum Beispiel, Interconnect-Probleme ist eigentlich die größte Fehlerquelle bei High Availability,
also, du hast ja, normalerweise, wir nehmen mal was ganz, wir nehmen mal was ganz klassisches
an, was ganz klassisches, du hast einen Netzwerkservice, wir reden gar nicht von Storage und sowas,
genau, was ganz Simples, sagen wir mal, du hast einen Loadbalancer, du hast einen Loadbalancer,
ja, ganz simpler Netzwerkservice, ich mach mal kurz ein bisschen Musik an, wenn ich's
finde, du hast einen Netzwerkservice, also, du hast einen Loadbalancer, Cluster, so, ein
Cluster muss, chat, ich weiß, es ist erst der erste, neun Uhr fünfzig, und ihr seid
alle noch besoffen, aber, wie viele Cluster-Notes brauchst du mindestens, damit du überhaupt
sinnvollerweise einen High Availability-Cluster aufbauen kannst?
Drei, das ist korrekt, der Chat ist auch schon High IQ morgens um neun Uhr fünfzig, das
ist richtig, drei, warum brauchst du drei, naja, um die Chance zu minimieren, oder um
die, um die Fehler zu minimieren, dass, wenn mal zwei Notes sich nicht einig sind, wer
jetzt der Master-Note ist, malen wir das mal kurz auf, der dritte Note muss übrigens
auch gar kein vollwertiger Note sein, aber gehen wir jetzt mal von aus, also, du hast
drei, machen wir das anders, machen wir das mal irgendwie, das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie so ein Emote jetzt, aber okay, so, du hast drei Loadbalancer-Notes, und wie verbindest
du die jetzt miteinander, du hast hier, du hast hier nen Switch, nur um zu zeigen, dass
auch Simplest High Availability nicht so einfach sein muss, du hast hier nen Switch, jetzt
könnte man hier auf die Idee kommen, naja, wir verbinden die Dinger mit dem Switch, oder
dann funktioniert das schon, das funktioniert auch, jetzt hast du aber das Problem, dass
der Switch hier ein Problem hat, dass die Netzwerk-Config hier irgendwie kaputt ist,
oder sagen wir mal sogar, dass der Switch kaputt ist, oder was auch immer, irgendwie gibt das
Netzwerk technisch Probleme, so, und was passiert jetzt, naja, was passiert jetzt, naja, das
hier ist ja ein Cluster, das ist, was auch immer man da verwendet jetzt, aber das funktioniert
alles ähnlich, also das hier ist ja quasi ein High Availability-Cluster, der nach außen
eine Cluster-IP hat, also sagen wir mal, alle Loadbalancer zusammen haben hier 1 und 2,
1, 6, 8, 5, 1, oder so, und jetzt ist das Ding, aktuell ist der hier der Meinung, er
ist der Masternode, jetzt geht das Netzwerk kaputt, so, Netzwerk ist procken, jetzt ist
das Ding, was machen die Teile denn jetzt, die stellen fest, der Masternode stellt fest,
oh fuck, ich sehe ja keine anderen zwei Nodes mehr, also sind die ja wohl kaputt, hm, und
der hier denkt, ich sehe ja auch keine anderen zwei Nodes mehr, also, also sind die wohl
kaputt, und der denkt das auch, und im Endeffekt, wenn du nicht aufpasst, hast du mal ratzfatz
auf einmal alle Cluster-Nodes, die der Meinung sind, sie sind jetzt Master, sind jetzt der
Masternode, weil sie müssen ja davon ausgehen, sie sind der Masternode, weil die anderen
zwei sind ja kaputt, sie selbst sind nicht kaputt, weil sie selbst wissen ja, oder es
kann auch umgedreht sein, so nach dem Motto hoch, ich bin jetzt kaputt, aber meistens
läuft es dann darauf raus, dass du mehrere Masternodes hast, Netzwerk kurz geruckelt,
und auf einmal hast du drei Masternodes und es geht nix mehr danach gescheit, deswegen,
damit du überhaupt gescheit High Availability machen kannst, musst du eigentlich, hier
Inter, brauchst du noch ein extra, also die einfachste Variante wäre tatsächlich, man
würde noch ein Interconnect-Switch hier unten drunter machen, ja, würdest du noch ein Interconnect-Switch
machen und würdest du irgendwie noch mal da drüber verbinden, oder aber, du verbindest
die wirklich alle noch mal miteinander, kannst du auch machen, und da sieht man schon, selbst
so eine simple Hochverfügbarkeitslösung, wo man denkt, kann doch nicht so schwierig
sein eine Netzwerkservice hochverfügbar zu machen, ist fehleranfälliger, wenn man es
nicht richtig macht, als ein einzelner Service, und da kann man ganz andere Fehlerquellen
bekommen, als man so denkt, also einfach nur drei Netzwerk-Nodes aufsetzen und sagen,
oh, krasse Hochverfügbarkeit ist jetzt alles viel besser, es ist wahrscheinlich über
längere Sicht mehr kaputt durch die Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, wenn man sie nicht richtig umsetzt, als
wenn man einfach eine Node fire und forget hinstellt, also da muss man aufpassen, das
ist gar nicht so, also das sieht immer, Raid ist ein weiteres Thema, viele Leute denken
sich, ach komm, ich will ja nicht, dass meine Daten weg sind, wenn eine Festplatte kaputt
geht, also machen wir ein bisschen Raid im Nass, als erstes muss man sagen, offensichtlicherweise
ist Raid für Backup-Zwecke nur bedingt geeignet, weil, wenn ich eine Datei aus Versehen lösche,
dann ist die weg, auf dem Raid, das Raid geht noch, aber die Datei ist weg, oder wenn ich
irgendeinen Verschlüsselungstrojaner oder sowas habe, der den Fileshare, ich muss mal
Logitech kurz starten, weil meine Tastatur keine richtigen, was ist das jetzt hier, ich
will einfach nur, dass meine Tastatur die richtigen RGB-Sachen anzeigt, ganz toll, exzellent,
geil, jetzt habe ich den Chat zugemacht, weil ich die Maustasten gedrückt habe, also das
nächste ist Raid, viele Leute denken sich auch, sie machen Raid, weil Raid viel hoch
verfügbarer ist, Raid ist nicht dazu da, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Daten nicht verloren gehen,
sondern Verfügbarkeit zu garantieren, also genau dafür, allerdings denken sich viele,
wir machen Raid an, dann sind wir sicherer drauf, also aus Versehen löchen, schützt
sich Raid nicht davor und irgendwelche Verschlüsselungstrojaner, die deine Fileshares verschlüsseln, schützt
sich Raid auch nicht davor, Raid schützt sich einzugleichen davor, dass wenn dir die Festplatte
abbraucht, dass der Service weiterhin verfügbar bleibt und selbst dann hast du Probleme, weil
viele Leute verwenden Raid 5, viele Leute verwenden Raid 5 und Raid 5 hat so ein paar
Probleme, zum Beispiel, ich glaube das ist nicht der Richtige und zwar, wenn wir jetzt
mal hier sagen, Raid 5, Number of Disks 3, 10TB, Calculate, nein das ist nicht das, was ich
haben will, das will ich haben, das will ich haben, also Raid 5, 10TB Platten sind denke
ich relativ normal, also 3, also das ist ja das, was viele Leute verwenden, so wir gucken
uns jetzt mal irgendwie Seagate, Ironwolf, 10TB an, was die für eine Fehlerrate hat,
dass wir auch was realistisches da mal eingeben, seht ihr es irgendwo, ich bin blind, hier,
10 hoch 5, 10, ok, also, das ist so ein normales Setup, da sieht man schon, so geil ist das
selbst in der kleinsten Ausführung nicht, guck mal, wir haben ein Raid 5 mit 13TB Platten,
also nicht mit 13TB, sondern mit 13TB Platten und jetzt geht eine Platte kaputt, das bedeutet
beim Raid 5 ja, dass die anderen beiden Platten perfekt lesbar sein müssen, um die dritte
Platte zu recovern und wir sehen schon, bei der Fehlerrate haben wir nur eine Chance von
85% dass das fehlerfrei recovert, 85%, also man könnte jetzt sagen, hey 85% ist ja schon
mal nicht verkehrt, aber, also würdet ihr in den Fahrstuhl steigen, wenn ihr wüsste
zu 15% könnt ihr abstürzen, also ich nicht, ich würde mir das wirklich gut überlegen
ob ich damit fahren würde, weil 15% ist ganz schön viel, so, aber nichts unabhängig davon,
es kommen ja Leute noch auf blöde Ideen, zum Beispiel die Anzahl der Platten in ihrem
Nass zu erhöhen, in viele Nasspassen, in viele kleineren Nasses passen 5 Platten rein,
oder 3 ist das mindeste 3, 4, 5 Platten, man passt mal auf, wenn man mal 4 Platten, 27%
wird schon langsam kritisch, also da würde ich mir wirklich überlegen, will ich wirklich
meine Daten da drauf legen, das ist bei weitem nicht so geil wie man sich das vorstellt,
was man machen kann ist Raid 6 verwenden, Raid 6 ist da deutlich, deutlich resistenter,
aber man verliert auch mehr Speicherplatz, dafür hast du schnelle Reads, muss man sich
einfach nur mal im Hinterkopf behalten, oftmals hat man mehr Probleme, das war mir nicht bewusst,
ja viele denken da nicht dran, viele denken Raid 5 easy, gar kein Problem, aber ist es
so? Du hast, was hast du für Platten drinne? Es geht um den Rebuild in dem Fall, und dass
der Rebuild nicht funktioniert, jaja also dein Raid funktioniert, dein Raid funktioniert
erst mal weiterhin, halt ziemlich Decrated und kaputt, aber es funktioniert weiterhin,
aber wenn du Rebuilden willst, sodass dein Raid wieder komplett intakt ist, musst du
ja die anderen Platten nahezu perfekt lesen können, dass du Rebuilden kannst, weil du
musst ja quasi die dritte Platte Rebuilden aus den anderen 2, und dazu müssen die ja
alle lesbar sein, und wenn du dann ein Problem bekommst, dass das Ding im Rebuild den Geist
darauf gibt, bzw. Sektoren nicht lesbar sind, da war es das halt mit dem Rebuild. Also wichtig
ist vor allem die Größe der Platte und was die angeben für Fehlerrate, also du hast zum
Beispiel wenn du 10TB Platten verwendest, so eine 0815 Platte hier, wie wir gerade geguckt
haben, 10TB hast du tatsächlich eine 20 oder 21%ige Chance, dass dein Rebuild nicht funktioniert,
das heißt nicht automatisch, dass du nichts mehr von diesem Raid runter bekommst, weil
es funktioniert ja mit 2 Platten auch noch, aber du hast halt vielleicht Leseprobleme,
und wenn du Rebuilden willst, kackst du ja halt im Zweifelsfall ab. Was bestimmt denn
die Read Error Rate, das was dein Festplattenhersteller angibt? Guck hier, du guckst dir einfach rein,
was dein Fest, hier, Non Recoverable Error Rate Max, einer in, ja da, 15 Nullen hinten
dran. Das klingt wenig, aber 10TB ist halt ganz schön viel, ein Speicher, und das dann
in Kombination aus mehreren Trives, wo alles fehlerfrei funktionieren muss, ist die Chance,
dass dein Raid fehlerfrei Rebuildet, tatsächlich 21% dass es in die Hose geht, und das will
man dann nicht haben. Ja das sind alles so Sachen, worauf ich letztendlich raus will
es, bevor wir uns das Video jetzt weiter angucken. Oftmals macht man sich mit Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen
oder besser gesagt mit vielleicht nicht ganz zu Ende gedachten Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen
mehr Probleme als gar keine Hochverfügbarkeitsmaßnahmen, so blöds klingt. Zumal man sich ja um die
ganzen Kram auch kümmern muss. Wie werden große Nasssysteme gesichert? Große Nasssysteme
sind meistens keine, wir schieben 6 Platten rein und machen Raid 5 drüber. Die machen
dann, also gibt natürlich verschiedene Abstufungen, also wenn du ein komplettes Storage System
kaufst, was natürlich auch als Nass fungieren kann, das ist dann quasi so ein eigenes Rack,
was du kriegst. Die sind intern oftmals, in mehreren Stufen kann man das glaube ich
am besten beschreiben. Die großen Storage Systeme sind intern meistens in mehrere Stufen
aufgeteilt. Du hast dann Sachen, die auf SSD, du hast da quasi SSD Cache mit drinne. Meistens
hast du so 3 Stufen. So nach dem Motto Daten, die oft gebraucht werden, sind halt auf SSDs,
die nächste Stufe sind schnelle Platten und dann hast du vielleicht noch eine dritte Stufe
irgendwie Standby Platten oder sowas. Du hast dann meistens sogar die Möglichkeit, in großem
Storage System, dich zu entscheiden, wie schnell soll das ganze sein. Dementsprechend teuer
ist es bzw. dementsprechend knapp ist der Speicher dann auch und du kannst dich auch
entscheiden, was du für eine Redundancy Strategie, also für Ausfall Strategie fährst. Dann machst
du z.B. sowas wie Rate 10 ist relativ beliebt. Rate 10 ist Rate 1 über 2 Rate Nulls oder
ist es ein Rate 0 über 2 Rate 1. Ich glaube es ist ein Rate 1 über 2 Rate Nulls. Sachen
wie Rate 10 ist da z.B. recht beliebt, allerdings auch nicht über das ganze System, sondern
immer nur über Teile. Und das unten drunter händelt dann halt die Storage Firmware. Und
ansonsten, wenn es noch ein größeres NAS System ist, wenn du noch kein komplettes Storage
System gekauft hast, wenn es ein größeres NAS System ist, dann musst du dir halt überlegen,
was du machst. Du kannst z.B. sowas nehmen wie Rate 50 oder sowas. Nee, nicht Rate 50.
Ihr zählt Mist. Keine Ahnung, was man da am besten nimmt. Du hast oftmals bei solchen
Sachen auch mehrere Standorte und dann hast du zweimal das gleiche NAS System, was permanent
über irgendwelche Glasfaserverbindungen gesüngt wird. Das kann dann aber die jeweilige Storage
Firmware, also bei den ganz großen Storages ist es so. Ich kann es jetzt z.B. sagen, bei
den ganz großen Storages ist es so, wir haben an zwei verschiedenen Standorten in Frankfurt
haben wir Storage Systeme stehen und die haben eine Dedicated Glasfaser Dark Fiber Verbindung.
Dark Fiber heißt übrigens nur Dark Fiber, weil die Dinger normalerweise rumliegen und
nicht benutzt werden. Und die haben quasi eine Dedicated Sync Verbindung zwischen den
Standorten nur für das Storage. Dann hast du schon mal ganz andere Probleme, aber auch
viele Probleme nicht mehr. Und das wichtigste ist, dass man tatsächlich ein Backup hat.
Die ganz teuren, die ganz super teuren Storage Systeme, die kamen früher bspw. in Kombination
mit einer Tape Library, so ob ihr sowas schon mal gesehen habt. Die haben dann automatisch
gebackupt. Ja, sowas hier. Wartet mal. Das ist heute glaube ich nicht mehr so angesagt,
aber ich kenne das. Ja. Tape Library. Da hast du Magnetbänder, wo automatisch gebackupt
wurde. Und das ist relativ high IQ dieses Ding, das rotiert und dreht auch teilweise
die Bänder, dass sie nicht verkleben und sowas. Da sind wir aber schon im wahnsinnig teuren
Enterprise Storage Segment. Du hast dann quasi einen Storage und ein Backup System als Tape
Library nebendran. Es hat was. Ich war ja früher, als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet
habe, bin ich ja morgens immer durch unsere Rechenzentren in Frankfurt gegangen und habe
geguckt, ob alles in Ordnung ist. Und ich kann euch sagen, so eine Tape Library hat
etwas meditatives, wenn man davor steht. Da kannst du ohne Probleme eine Viertelstunde
reingucken und du siehst eigentlich nichts, außer so einen komischen Arm da rumfahren.
Du kannst ohne Probleme eine Viertelstunde reingucken, ohne dass es dir langweilig wird.
Da reden wir jetzt aber halt auch schon von, ich weiß gar nicht, was sowas kostet. Ich
würde auch mal sagen, so komplette Storage, da sind wir schon im Millionenbereich wahrscheinlich.
Mit ordentlichem Ausbau. Keine Ahnung, was sowas kostet mit Storage und Backup Library
und allem. So werden meistens richtig große professionelle Storage Systeme gebackupt.
Heute weiß ich das nicht mehr, ehrlich gesagt. Weiß ich nicht, wie das gemacht wird. Ich
kenne das noch, zu Zeiten, wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, da gab es so Sachen wie Tape
Library beim Storage dabei, bzw. zum Storage passen. Wie man das heute macht, ehrlich gesagt,
keine Ahnung. Also, ich kenne bloß zwei Sachen. Sync zwischen mehreren Standorten auf die
gleichen Storage Systeme, über eine eigene Glasfaser, gemietete Glasfaserleitung, Infrastruktur
und halt Backup über Tape Libraries. Was anderes kenne ich nicht. Es gibt bestimmt
noch mehr Varianten. Ja, wir haben auch noch was. Wir haben auch noch was. Also, wie gesagt,
ich gucke mir das immer noch gerne an. Am besten in zwei Brandzonen, am besten ist,
wenn du unterschiedliche Standorte hast. Ich meine klar, theoretisch kannst du es weitertreiben
und sagen, ja, zwei Standorte in der gleichen Stadt sind auch blöd. Guck mal, dass du
zwei Standorte hast, auf unterschiedlichen Teilen der Welt oder dann fünf Standorte
auf unterschiedlichen. Man kann es immer noch weiterspinnen. Das ist ja tatsächlich
eines der Vorteile von dieser ganzen Cloud-Geschichte. Das ist zum ersten Mal jetzt, dass jeder die
Möglichkeit hat, wenn er denn will und ein bisschen Geld in die Hand nimmt, wirklich
seine Services hoch verfügbar aufzubauen. Das hattest du ja vorher nicht. Wer konnte
sich vorher? Wer konnte sich vorher? Nee, das ist tatsächlich in dem Fall ein Backup,
weil der Sync ist meistens asynchron. Also es ist kein Backup, wie historisch irgendwie
die Visa ist aus vor 48 Tagen. Aber meistens ist es ein asynchrones Backup. Das heißt,
wenn jetzt was kaputt geht, kannst du das Backup direkt wieder zurückspielen. Das letzte.
Wenn du Pech hast, dass es nicht eine Minute vorgelaufen ist. Meistens läuft das zweimal
am Tag oder so und einmal nachmittags, einmal nachts oder irgendwie sowas. Ist ja eine Frage,
wie man es einstellt. Du hast jetzt zum ersten Mal die Möglichkeit, einen Service aufzubauen
mit den ganzen Cloud-Providern und Serverless-Geschichten, die es heute gibt, die wirklich hoch verfügbar
ist und auch theoretisch irgendwelche Kriegen standhalten würde, wenn du es übertreibst.
Man hätte jetzt wirklich Bedenken, dass hier die Bombe einschlägt in Frankfurt. Ich möchte
aber, dass mein Service weiterläuft. Ich könnte heute mit aktueller Cloud-Technik mein Service
so weit aufbauen, dass er nicht nur super performant überall auf der Welt läuft, sondern
ich könnte auch dafür sorgen, dass er weiterläuft, obwohl der Main-Server in Frankfurt vielleicht
kaputt ist. Du kannst heute Datenbanken verteilt über die Welt machen. Du kannst heute so Sachen
wie Anycasts, Loadbalancing machen. Relativ easy über Cloud-Provider. Also, dass quasi
die Kunden in Asien den Service in Asien verwenden, die Kunden in NA und die aus Europa, also
dass die auch zum nächsten hinkommen. Du kannst heute tatsächlich auch als Nicht-Rechenzentrumsbetreiber,
der Millionen in Infrastruktur steckt, deine Service relativ easy, super hoch verfügbar
aufbauen, dass sie theoretisch Bombenangriffen standhalten würde auf verschiedene Teile
der Welt. Das ging vorher nicht so. Früher hättest du dir deutlich mehr Gedanken machen
müssen. Entweder hättest du das selbst bauen müssen oder du hättest halt gucken müssen,
dass du über mehrere Hoster verteilt irgendwie deine Infrastruktur relativ aufbaust mit Umschaltmechanismen
und dann wird es trotzdem problematisch bei sowas wie Anycasts, Loadbalancing, weil das
machst du mal nicht einfach so selbst. Kannst du gar nicht selbst, weil du bist ja kein
Provider. Du hast ja kein eigenes BGP-Netz und sowas. Also, du darfst auch keine Sachen
announcen als 0-15-VM-Mieter. Du kannst als normaler User nicht einfach Anycast-Loadbalancing
machen. Du kannst DNS-Loadbalancing machen, aber Anycast wird schwierig. Also Anycast
ist, dass du eine IP auf mehreren Teilen der Welt hast. Also zum Beispiel, da brauch ich
nicht so lange vor mich hin labere, zum Beispiel der Klassiker, der Google-DNS. Guck mal, ich
habe einen Ping von 14. Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, ich gehe wahrscheinlich nach Frankfurt irgendwo,
wenn ich den Google-DNS anpinge. Wenn ich den Google-DNS anpinge aus China, na gut,
keine Ahnung, China ist immer ein schlechtes Beispiel. Sag mal, ich bin jetzt in New York
und pinge den Google-DNS an, dann habe ich aber auch nur 14 Millisekunden Latenz. Wie
kann das sein? Ja gut, ganz einfach, den Server gibt es einfach schlicht und ergreifend bzw.
den Server. Die IP gibt es einfach mehrfach auf der Welt. Und über geschicktes Routing
bzw. dass man sagt, hey, die Route ist jetzt billiger oder die Route ist jetzt kürzer,
kommt man immer bei der IP raus, die näher an einem dran ist. Und das ist halt eine Sache,
das kannst du nicht als 0815 Server-Mieter von irgendwie 3 VMs machen, sowas. Das funktioniert
nur, wenn du quasi ein Provider bist, wenn du BGP-Netze annoucen kannst, Routen annoucen
kannst, dann funktioniert das und das kannst du nicht glücklicherweise, sonst wäre das
Internet laufen kaputt, wenn das jeder machen könnte. Und für solche Sachen brauchst du
irgendeinen Provider, brauchst du einen Cloud-Anbieter, der das supportet. Und sowas ist heute aber
easy für jeden möglich. Also ihr könnt heute relativ einfach mit einem Cloud-Load-Balancer,
sag mal bei Google zum Beispiel, mit dem Google Cloud-Load-Balancer könnt ihr total easy
sowas hier machen. Anycast IPs, für eure Services weltweit. Ja, aber egal, so viel
mal zu Cloud-Geschichten. Battlefield 3-Zeiten, hey, mir würde es ja reichen, ich will Battlefield
3-Zeiten gar nicht zurück. Auch wenn das eine geile Zeit war, also ich hätte vielleicht
gerne so die Mentalität der Leute und den Daily Battlefield-Grind mit Leuten zurück,
aber Battlefield 3 nicht zwangsläufig, weil ich bin der Meinung, sie sollen eben mal
ein ordentliches neues Battlefield machen und nicht so ein Rock-Crepierer wie 2042.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass ich mehrere Stunden am Tag wieder Battlefield
spiele, wenn es halt was taugt. Ich spiele in MMO zurzeit wieder mehrere Stunden am Tag,
gar kein Problem, aber das Game muss halt was tauchen, was Battlefield 2042 nicht macht.
Ja, OVH, das ist da, wo es gefackelt hat, ja. Tja, so siehts aus. So, also jetzt gucken
wir uns das Video mal fertig an. Ich hab jetzt ganze 2 Minuten 50 geguckt und hab irgendwie
eine halbe Stunde über Cloud-Technik, High-Availability und sonst was gelabert, aber so mögt ihr das
ja, ne? Was? Was? Was ist das da unten? Windows! Was zum...
Was ist das wieder für ein Scheiß hier unten, man? Ist das ein Nook? Sieht ein bisschen
so aus, ja. Warum blende das da unten so eine Kackleiste ein? Alter! Kubernetes! Wir testen
jetzt mal was, wir testen jetzt mal was, ob das in Firefox auch so ist. Katie Perry lässt
sich Essen mit Lieferando liefern. Man kann diesen ganzen, man kann das Internet eigentlich
ohne Adblocker gar nicht verwenden. Schon geil, oder? Naja, okay. Accept. Ach ja, im Firefox
geht das. Guck mal, im Firefox, im Firefox kann ich rüber wechseln, kein Problem. Im
Chrome nicht, also demnächst müssen wir wohl Firefox verwenden. Wo Zura die ganzen Sachen
hat, wird er wahrscheinlich immer durch euch erzählen. Okay, wir machen mal ein bisschen
weiter. Also, wir haben bis jetzt gelernt, eigentlich hat er seine Virtualisierungsinfrastruktur,
um darauf einen Kubernetes Cluster laufen zu lassen. Okay, das heißt, die eigentliche
Frage ist, was lässt er alles auf seinem Kubernetes Cluster laufen?
Kubernetes? Ja, und was läuft jetzt da drauf? Mal ganz davon abziehen, also ich meine, was
hat er denn hier insgesamt? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. Ja, ich meine, 10 VMs ist
jetzt auch nicht so, als wäre das, wenn das das Minimal ist, super krass zu handeln oder
so. Alter, the fuck? Eine Kubernetes Testumgebung für sein Kubernetes Cluster, der dann wieder
dafür da ist, um Kubernetes zu sein. Okay, weiter, weiter. Was, was, was, was macht er?
Was läuft denn darauf jetzt? Okay, Nass. Was mache ich denn mit S3 daheim? Ich überlege
gerade den Anwendungszweck für S3 bei mir daheim. Okay, ja. Okay, weiter, weiter.
Ich denke mir beinahe gar nicht im ganzen Sinn auf what the heck.
Okay, weiter, weiter, weiter.
What the fuck? Warum?
Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen. Zu Lernzwecken ist immer okay.
Die einfachste Variante wäre gewesen, einfach den Raspberry Pi Zero dann zum Primary DNS
zu machen, durch den Rest zu sparen. Weil performance technisch ist es jetzt nicht so, als ist DNS
so problematisch.
Ganz ehrlich, das kann man ja schon so machen. Es ist ja nicht, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie
so ein böses Setup, was man nicht verwenden darf. Aber ich frage mich halt einfach nur,
warum sollte ich mir daheim so ein Akt, so ein Aufwand machen? Ich mein, er könnte einfach
sein Raspberry Pi nehmen als Primary DNS und gut ist. Also wenn er sicherstellen will,
dass alles noch funktioniert, was Namensauflösungen angeht, auch wenn sein Rack ausgeschaltet
ist, dann nehmen wir halt einfach den Raspberry Pi standardmäßig.
Wie gesagt, man kann das machen, das ist gar kein Ding. Kann man machen, wenn man üben
will, ist ja alles in Ordnung. Aber wenn ich mir überlege, an wie vielen Stellen da irgendwas
hängen kann und du bist erst mal drei Stunden am Debuggen, woran es jetzt hängt, ja, irgendwie
switcht irgendwie um. Es wurde nicht richtig announced, der Switch denkt immer noch, er
muss dahin, dabei ist die IP jetzt da, da kann so viel schief gehen und du musst erst
mal Stunden gucken, was ist es denn jetzt?
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr was ich hab? Ich hab gar kein Adblock DNS mehr, ich verwende halt
UBlock und ich hab auf meinem Router ein paar lokale DNS Namen konfiguriert, so 20 oder
so. Fertig. Adblock, Adblock DNS verwende ich nicht mehr, seit es leider auf den meisten
Seiten, die ich verwende, nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Zum Beispiel Twitch kannst du damit nicht blocken, YouTube kannst du damit nicht richtig
blocken, vielleicht geht YouTube wieder, aber gegen eine ganze Zeit lang nicht. Twitch
hat ja schon Probleme hier mit, im Browser, Adblocker. Was ist das da unten?
Okay, das gibt das, das gibt wir jetzt mal. Er hat gesagt, er benutzt kein DHCP von PyHole,
dass er kein DHCP nutzt, hat er nicht gesagt.
Developers, developers, developers. Ja, ja, das hat er ja oft genug erzählt, aber
das ist ja nicht so, als hätte er die anderen zwei schon gebraucht.
Ich mag Portainer nicht, ich mach entweder Docker Command Line oder irgendeinen Docker
Compose Fall, wenn es was einfaches sein muss und fertig.
Wisst ihr was deutlich weniger Challenger, deutlich weniger Challenge, Challenge wäre
für ihn? Einfach gar kein Kubernetes Cluster.
Ich bin sehr glücklich, dass ich die Docker-Kontainer in einer neuen, kleineren Cluster
mitgebracht habe.
Und jetzt sind sie drin.
Aber lass uns kurz darüber reden.
Wie ihr seht, habe ich drei Clusters, eine heißt Local, eine heißt Cluster01 und eine
heißt Cluster02.
Lass uns zu Local sprechen.
So, dieser Local Cluster ist für Ranscher gebraucht, das ist es, das ist alles, was
bei Ranscher gebraucht wird, das ist alles, was bei Ranscher gebraucht wird, das ist alles,
was bei Ranscher gebraucht wird.
Und dann haben wir gerade, wir haben hier über die Kameras drüber geredet, was denn
jetzt eigentlich darauf läuft, was man denn am Endeffekt dann auch wirklich benutzt, also
was läuft darauf, was man eben am Endeffekt benutzt und einen Mehrwert dadurch hat.
Aktuell haben wir nur Infrastruktur und Infrastrukturmanagement.
71Deployments, ich weiß nicht was er da treibt, keine Ahnung.
benutzt noch jemand docker swarm ja ja es gibt leute die benutzen docker swarm dort wo ich mich
beworben habe nicht dort nicht dort wo es jetzt was geworden ist die benutzen doch docker swarm
haben sie mir erzählt
ja wie fast alles
すごい
Das ist... alter, das ist so krasser auf der Kiste.
Was?
Das ist so krasser auf der Kiste.
So was.
Kommt mal.
Das ist jetzt wieder nur Verwaltung auf sich selbst zu verwalten, man.
This is running on top of K3S and it's dedicated to Rancher only.
Then we have Cluster01, which is my user workload cluster.
Okay.
This is where all of the stuff I want to run in Kubernetes runs.
Ja, erzähl mal, was gibt's denn da?
This is the same cluster that I've been running for a couple years now, it's just grown.
And you saw I had more nodes, but that's the nice thing about Kubernetes.
I add more nodes as I run out of compute or disk space or even RAM,
and it will add that node to the cluster and even everything out
and make my services highly available.
They'll eventually move over to that node as they need to.
Within this cluster I have...
Wenn bei dem mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert,
ist er erst mal fünf Stunden damit beschäftigt,
rauszufinden, an welcher Stelle es hängt.
Many things that we're going to talk about, like reverse proxies, CMS systems,
monitoring systems, Gravana...
Mich würde interessieren, was läuft denn jetzt wirklich drauf?
Ethias, you name it, it's all running inside of Kubernetes.
And this cluster, not that it matters.
Es ist immer ganz besonders toll, das Monitoring-System
auf der Plattform laufen zu lassen, die es monitoren soll.
Da kann ja nichts schiefgehen.
Was denn zum Beispiel?
Ja, okay, und was läuft hinter Traffic?
Ich will einfach wissen, warum, also was läuft denn jetzt da drauf?
Okay, Home Assistant.
Wahnsinn!
Ein ganzer Service läuft da drauf, boah, Alter.
Nee, mir ist die Zeit nicht zu schade.
Ich rant ein bisschen drüber rum, das ist wunderbar.
Alter, wisst ihr, ich denke schon immer, bei mir ist es komplizierter
und ja, keine Ahnung, unsinnig kompliziert schon im Vergleich zu dem,
was viele haben.
Viele Leute haben daheim eine Fritzbox stehen, fertig aus,
und es funktioniert wunderbar.
Ja, damit bin ich nicht so ganz zufrieden,
dass ich zum Beispiel ein extra IoT-VLAN habe
und ein paar unterschiedliche Netze und so.
Das ist ja schon mehr als die meisten Leute da,
aber das ist einfach komplett Kosten-Nutzen-Relation nicht gewahrt.
Also, ich koste meine ich jetzt nicht unbedingt das Geld, was das kostet.
Ich glaube, die Hardware, die man da hat, ist auch teuer,
aber vor allem der Zeitaufwand, also der Aufwand für das,
was man davon hat, steht in keinem Verhältnis.
Okay, jetzt kommt Kubernetes Storage.
Okay, ich will einfach wissen, was da drauf laufen lässt.
Das ist ja wirklich was Neues.
Ja, ja, alles schön und gut, aber was läuft denn jetzt drauf?
Traffic ist tatsächlich nice, den verwende ich auch gerne,
allerdings nur, wenn man ihn automatisiert konfigurieren kann.
Traffic-Config von Hand ist echt der größte Abfall überhaupt.
Naja, wie? Nur drei?
Moin, Chris, aber nur drei Reverse-Proxys, das ist aber zu wenig.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass der mindestens acht hat.
Ihr habt Traffic verworfen, was macht ihr jetzt?
Man gibt ja ein paar klassische Variante, wie in den Nginx.
Proxy-Cuddy, also ich mag ja persönlich Cuddy für einfache Sachen.
Äh, whoops, Nginx, Moment, wo sind wir hier?
Okay, ich will einfach nur mal wissen, was da wirklich drauf läuft.
Hab ich auch eine Weile verwendet, es ist wirklich geil.
Es ist wirklich geil für Leute, die einfach nur Container starten wollen
oder einfach nur, ich glaube, das ist eine Vue.js Anwendung mit ein bisschen Express.js Backend und so.
Leute, die einfach nur mal starten wollen und ein paar Raspberry Pis pingen wollen bei sich daheim
und einfach nur wissen wollen, ist es up oder down, ist es gut.
Mir haben leider ein paar Kleinigkeiten gefehlt.
Zum Beispiel, dass man so Sachen wie Festplattenbelegung nicht gescheit überwachen kann damit,
außer mit ganz vielen Tricks, dass du keine richtige History hast, also kannst du auch nicht gucken,
hey, wie oft wird denn der Plattenplatz beim Recorder knapp und sowas,
dass man nicht ordentlich Zertifikatablaufdaten überwachen konnte,
aber für eine simple Monitoringlösung up, down, ist das wirklich nice.
Ich hab jetzt daheim tatsächlich ein Zabix laufen,
auch wenn ich Zabix gerade von der Konfiguration her echt mega abartig finde
und auch von der Optik und dem Dashboard ist es nicht schön.
Ja, gut.
Uuuuh, Leute, uuuuh, Discord.
Ich habe mir nie wirklich im Detail angeguckt, weil die so ein komisches Lizenzmodell hatten.
Du kriegst irgendwie nur 20 Hosts kostenlos oder sowas oder 20 Services kostenlos
und ansonsten kannst du die Community-Version verwenden, die nichts mehr mit der normalen Version zu tun hat.
Das ist ein bisschen verschreckt bisher.
Leute, Grafana, wisst ihr was das geilste an Grafana ist?
Das geilste an Grafana ist, es sieht cool aus, wenn du was Cooles zeigen musst.
Vieles der Grafen, gerade die Standard-Dashboards sind komplett useless.
Also ihr müsst euch mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Haben die eine Demo? Ich habe hier gerade nichts.
Ich sag doch, das ist Infrastruktur, um Infrastruktur zu verwalten hier.
Node-Exporter-Full, also es ist leider nicht gut.
Ganz ehrlich, das sieht cool aus, aber 95% der Crafts da drin sind komplett useless.
Das bringt dir überhaupt gar nichts im täglichen benutzen und vor allem auch nicht, um irgendwie Fehler rauszukriegen.
Es ist praktisch, die Daten zu haben, wenn du nicht weißt, was gewesen ist.
Also wenn jetzt dein Service ruckelt und du weißt nicht, warum und du willst gucken, was ist, dann ist es tatsächlich schon praktisch.
Aber wie gesagt, 95% der Crafts hier drin noch nicht einmal reingeguckt.
Das coole an Grafana ist, es sieht gut aus, wenn der Chef ins Büro kommt und du kannst seinen Grafana-Dashboard zeigen.
Cool, nice. Aber ansonsten, es ist wirklich nicht einfach.
Und es braucht schon eine gewisse Hirnleistung dafür, um ordentliche, aussagekräftige Grafana-Dashboards zu machen,
wo auch sinnvolle Werte erfasst werden und die so aggregiert werden, dass was Sinnvolles bei rauskommt.
Also irgendein Dashboard über die gleiche Metrik von 98 Systemen zu haben, irgendeinen Graf zu haben mit den Default-Settings über 98 Systeme von der gleichen Metrik bringt dir in der Regel nichts.
Ja, du siehst, okay, hier sind alle Server runtergegangen.
Aber was du ja oftmals wissen möchtest, ist dann zum Beispiel die Kombination aus.
Ja, woran hat es denn jetzt gelingen? War der RAM voll? War das Netzwerk irgendwie ausgelastet?
Gab es irgendwelche, wie viele aktive Verbindungen hatte ich?
Und das Ganze quasi so zu bauen, dass du dann auch was Sinnvolles draus erkennen kannst, ist wirklich nicht einfach in Grafana.
Die Möglichkeiten sind da, aber einfach in Default-Dashboard drauf klatschen, ist es halt nicht mitgetan.
Dann hast du sowas hier, wo ich mir denke, ja, nice, Server-CPU-Usage.
Und jetzt ist rot jetzt gut, ist rot jetzt schlecht, sind Lücken gut, sind Lücken schlecht, blau wie was wo.
Man weiß es nicht. Und das geht ja noch, da sind ja noch nicht mal viele.
Das ist doch immer die Herausforderung von Big Data.
Okay, ich hätte jetzt, du hast recht, ich hätte jetzt Grafana nicht unbedingt Big Data genannt.
Aber natürlich, wenn man cool sein will, das mache ich ab jetzt, das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Wenn irgendwelche Grafana-Dashboards nicht ordentlich sind, dass man mit anfangen kann,
dann werde ich im nächsten Meeting auch mal sagen, das ist die Herausforderung von Big Data.
Das finde ich richtig gut, weil das klingt wichtig und irgendwie zutreffend, ja.
Das merke ich mir, das merke ich mir.
Wenn wieder einer ankommt und sagt, Mann, sind die Grafana-Dashboards scheiße, sage ich,
was ist denn da die Herausforderung von Big Data?
Und dann sagt keiner was drauf, weil sich alle denken, was will da Max uns damit jetzt eigentlich sagen.
Aber das ist gut, so habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen.
Die Meinung zu Observium habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich weiß, das ist glaube ich ein Fork von Libre NMS oder sowas oder von Open NMS.
Ich habe ihn noch nicht verwendet.
Das ist für Netzwerkzeuge wohl recht cool.
So als generelles Monitoring-System wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Ich glaube, hauptsächlich geht das ja auch über SNMP und diesem ganzen Zeug,
was halt für Netzwerkgeräte gut ist für Überwachung von Services,
zur Überwachung von Servern, von irgendwelchen Diensten ist SNMP jetzt nicht so das Geilste.
Nagios, Leute, Nagios.
Ich habe ein weiches Herz für Nagios.
Ich meine, ich würde heute nicht unbedingt ein neues Nagios installieren, aber ich mag Nagios.
Das liegt daran, dass ich mich während meiner Ausbildungszeit um einen Nagios Server kümmern musste.
Weil wie gesagt, meine Ausbildungszeit war ja nicht, ich wurde ausgebildet,
sondern ich musste irgendwas machen, ohne dass ich wusste, was ich eigentlich machen muss.
Und dann musste es irgendwie funktionieren.
Also nicht, dass ich eine Ausbildung gehabt hätte in der Ausbildung so richtig.
Und ich habe mich da um Nagios gekümmert.
Und ich mag auch die Nagios-Config.
Und du kannst dir in der Nagios-Config auch Settings vererben und sowas.
Das kann man richtig cool machen.
Also ich mag Nagios, auch wenn ich sagen würde,
ich würde Nagios heute nicht mal wirklich neu einführen irgendwo,
wenn es natürlich ein bestehendes System gibt.
Ich habe damals in der Ausbildung, kann mich auch daran erinnern,
wie hieß das Ding, wie hieß das Ding von Nagios?
War das der NAPA-Agent?
War das der Nagios-Agent?
Hieß das Ding nicht NAPA-Agent oder so?
Ich habe zumindest den Nagios-Agent damals selbst kompiliert noch
für drei verschiedene Target-Systeme.
Das war CentOS Debian.
Und jetzt kommt es Suse.
Wir hatten damals noch Suse für Telefonanlagen und sowas.
Also nicht für die Telefonanlage selbst,
sondern irgendwie für die Verwaltungsgeschichte von Telefonanlagen.
Es war Suse.
Dann musste ich den Nagios-Agent damals kompilieren
für ein Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur-Ur als Suse,
für den Debian und für Red Hat, also CentOS.
Und ich kann euch sagen, das war wahrscheinlich der ausschlaggebende Punkt,
warum ich Suse nicht mag und bis heute nicht verwende.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich mit Suse in Kontakt komme,
ist es mich abfuckt und ich nichts damit zu tun haben will.
Kommt wahrscheinlich daher.
Und noch mal Fun-Fact zu alten Dingern.
Dort, wo ich aktuell arbeite, haben wir auch ein super tolles,
nicees Konstrukt und zwar es gibt eine Datenbank-Software.
Das ist, frag mich nicht, irgendein Ur-Altes Oracle.
Das ist so alt, das Oracle, was da drauf ist.
Leute, habt ihr mal ein bisschen Plan von Oracle?
Wie alt ist Oracle? Was war das, 6, 8 oder sowas?
Nee, nicht Oracle Linux.
15, 15, 12, 12.
12.
Von wann ist Oracle 12?
2013.
Ah, das ist auch ein bisschen neu.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist dann ist es eher.
Nee.
Irgendwie sowas hier. 10, 10 noch was.
Zumindest wir haben...
Alter, mir läuft die Nase.
Wir haben ein Red Hat-System laufen.
Das ist ein, jetzt haltet euch fest,
das ist ein Red Hat 6 getarnt als Red Hat 4.
Oder Red Hat 5.
Nee, es ist ein Red Hat 6 getarnt als Red Hat 4.
Warum?
Weil die Datenbank, die da drauf läuft,
ein Red Hat 4-System erwartet.
Die guckt in etc-redhat-release oder irgendwo rein.
Ich glaube, etc-redhat-release ist es.
Und wenn da nicht steht, dass es ein Red Hat Enterprise Linux 4 ist,
startet sie nicht.
Das heißt, man hat ein Red Hat 6 installiert,
um darauf dann ein Red Hat 4 vorzugaukeln.
Und Red Hat 6 ist ja auch schon komplett out of alles, was es gibt.
Und dieses System gibt es immer noch.
Und dieses System wird irgendwie einmal im Quartal eingeschaltet,
um dort irgendwelche Daten noch rauszuziehen.
Sonst ist es aus.
So, jetzt wird es aber echt mal langsam Zeit,
dass er uns erklärt, was er dann eigentlich darauf benutzt.
Also, Spoiler, ich kenne das Video nicht,
aber ich spoiler trotzdem schon mal.
Wahrscheinlich nichts wirklich Relevantes.
Verwendet jemand von euch das Grafana-Alerting?
Das haben die ja eingeführt.
Also, dieses Unified Grafana-Alerting,
das haben die ja eingeführt vor einem Jahr oder so ungefähr.
Ich habe da noch keinen bisher gehört, gesehen, der das verwendet.
Und ich selbst habe es auch noch nicht verwendet.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, das ist es.
Grafana ist cool drauf zu gucken,
aber die Grafen so zu machen, dass man auch was handfestes,
aussagekräftiges hat, ist tatsächlich schwierig.
By the way, man könnte einfach so was Simples wie Syslog verwenden,
wenn man wirklich Logs zentral einsammeln will.
Aber ich glaube, das ist zu einfach.
Es ist ziemlich leicht, alles in Bezug darauf,
wie es mit anderen Logging-Solutions aussehen kann.
Aber ich glaube, eine der besten Dinge bei Loki ist,
dass es diesen Container-Modell folgt.
Also, ein Container zuerst oder Cloud-native.
Was ich meine, ist, dass die meisten Container
direkt zu Standard-Out sind, wenn sie Logs haben.
Dann habe ich im Keller einen Raspberry Pi.
Für die Kamera noch einen Raspberry Pi.
Man könnte sagen, ja, vielleicht möchte ich
von meinem Router noch sammeln.
Sind wir bei 6.
Für den 3D-Drucker, den Raspberry Pi, sind wir bei 7.
Im Wohnzimmer könnte man sagen,
ich möchte vielleicht für den da,
wo man Fernseher aufnehmen kann, recorden,
haben wir 8 Sohlen. Ich glaube, das war es.
Also, mit sehr viel gutem Willen komme ich auf 8 Systeme
bei mir daheim.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich schon deutlich mehr.
Also, wo ich eventuell Logs einsammeln will,
von meinen Desktops und so will ich ja keinen Log,
Tablets will ich ja keinen Logs einsammeln.
Sagen wir mal 8 Kisten, 8 Kisten.
Ich habe wirklich sehr großzügig gerechnet.
Dafür brauche ich kein irgendwie krasses
Log-Auswertungszeug, wo es sinnvoll sein könnte,
ist Log-Auswertung in Form von,
hey, ich habe jetzt Beispiels.
Gehen wir mal zum Beispiel von unten im Keller
für die Heizung.
Das Programm, was die Heizungsdaten ausliest,
kackt ab und zu ab.
Und der einzige Weg, es gescheit mitzubekommen,
dass es abkackt bzw. nicht abkackt,
sondern Connection-Probleme hat,
ist, wenn es Errors in das Log schreibt.
Okay, das kann man sich überlegen,
ob man das nicht einsammelt,
wenn seine Monitoring-Lösung quasi es mitbekommt,
wenn das Auslesen der Heizung nicht funktioniert.
Das ist okay.
Aber normalerweise eine Log-Auswertung daheim
bei 8 Kisten.
Wozu?
Außerdem brauche ich keine Log-Auswertung.
Das kann ich immer noch machen mit irgendeinem
Notexporter, einfach greppen, gucken,
ob in dem Log was drinne steht.
Wozu brauche ich da eine super,
zentrale Log-Sammlung für daheim?
Ich brauche keine zentrale Auswertung.
Kein Full-Text-Search über meine Logs
und solche Geschichten daheim.
Das sind 8 Notes.
Ich habe schon viel.
Die meisten Leute haben daheim vielleicht,
wenn es hochkommt, ihr nass, fertig aus.
Da kannst du dich im Zweifelsfall
schlicht und ergreifend,
wenn du wissen willst, was mit dem Host ist,
kannst du dich einfach per SSH darauf einloggen
und ins Log gucken.
So was soll gehen.
Natürlich, wenn das Ding Probleme hat
und komplett am verrecken ist und ich mich nicht
mehr darauf einloggen kann, ist das mit Logs schwierig.
Das ist auch nicht so, als kommt es jeden Tag
dreimal vor.
Das ist auch wieder so ein Ding, wo ich bedenke,
eigentlich brauchst du es daheim nicht.
Was empfiehlst du für eine Monitoring-Software?
Das kommt...
Okay, 5 Minuten, ich fasse mich kurz.
Das kommt ganz entscheidend darauf an,
was du machen willst.
Es gibt da
mittlerweile mehr...
Also, fangen wir mal an.
Läuft das Zeug bei dir?
Beziehungsweise ist das irgendwie deine
eigene Infrastruktur, weil wenn nicht,
wenn du irgendwelche Cloud-Services verwendest,
könnte es sogar sein, dass das,
was der jeweilige Anbieter
bietet,
voll und ganz ausreicht.
Notifications, wenn was
down geht,
irgendwelche Connection-Limits
oder sowas.
Vielleicht reicht das, was der Anbieter
out of the box bietet, voll und ganz aus,
dann brauchen wir schlicht und ergreifend gar nichts
und nimmt einfach das, was der Anbieter hat.
Wenn man das verwenden kann.
Ansonsten ist natürlich
die große Preisfrage, was will man machen?
Was will man monitoren?
Möchte man hauptsächlich
klassische Sachen wie Is Up, Is Down
monitoren?
RAM-Auslastung, CPU-Auslastung,
Response-Times,
vielleicht
noch Zertifikate, die ablaufen
und sowas.
Alles das ganz klassisches
Monitoring, wie man das seit 30 Jahren macht.
Dann würde ich sowas nehmen wie
Zabbix
oder
irgendeinen der Nagios-Abkömmlinge
von
Ichinga
und Checkmk und was nicht alles.
Es gibt nicht persönlich Zabbix.
Wer auf Windows steht und sich den Müll geben will,
kann auch PRTG verwenden.
PRTG selbst ist ziemlich gut,
was ich gesehen habe. Hab ich nie was großartig mit gemacht.
Aber das, was ich gesehen habe, ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
Aber es ist Windows-Only
und Windows-Only ist halt
nix, was man haben will.
Also entweder, wie gesagt, für so klassische Sachen
sowas wie Zabbix,
Nagios oder
Checkmk,
Ichinga, sowas in dieser Richtung,
was es in dieser Richtung gibt.
Ich persönlich mag da Zabbix, auch wenn die
Config ein bisschen eklig ist.
Also wenn du so klassische Sachen monitoren willst,
dann sowas.
Wenn es ganz simpel daheim sein soll,
auch was in der Richtung, genau.
Das ist auch sehr nice.
Wenn du einfach nur wissen willst, ist mein Raspberry Pi
ab, ist mein Raspberry Pi
kaputt
oder ist
der Webservice auf meinem Raspberry Pi
noch erreichbar. Dann kannst du UptimeKuma
nehmen, das ist wirklich nice.
Das hört aber schon auf, wenn du so Sachen überprüfen
willst, wie ist die CPU-Auslastung
am Limit oder
läuft meine Festplatte voll.
Das kannst du damit schon nicht mehr machen.
Aber wenn man wirklich nur was ganz Simples
Service up und down
braucht,
ist UptimeKuma das beste, was man so
daheim verwenden kann.
So aus.
Eine schöne Demo zu.
Gucken wir uns jetzt mal an.
Irgendwann, demnächst.
Demo ends.
Admin.
1,2,3,4,5,6
Massive.
Was?
So.
Das ist tatsächlich die aller simpelste Variante.
Das kann man selbst, Docker-Container
und so weiter.
Dann kann ich jetzt sowas hinzufügen, wie zum Beispiel
Du kannst
ablaufend ein Zertifikat überprüfen, aber du
hast keine schöne Übersicht darüber.
Du bekommst bloß eine Meldung
in 20 Tagen, aber du siehst
es auch im Webinterface nicht. Machen wir mal hier.
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal HTTPS.
Google.
Google.com
Sekunden.
Erweitert.
Benachrichtigung, ablaufendes Zertifikat.
Blablabla.
Speichern. Yep. Was?
Ach so, ja. Google.
Speichern.
So. Und dann hat man sowas hier.
Hat man eine coole Übersicht drüber.
Wenn, wenn die simplen Sachen
so, also wenn das einem ausreicht,
ist das wirklich cool?
Mir reicht's nicht ganz.
Es macht
so 90 Prozent von dem,
was ich für meinen Heimmonitoring
bräuchte, macht es. Allerdings
nicht alles. Ja, zum Beispiel
hätte ich gerne einen Graph
über die Festplattenauslastung
von meinem Fernsehrekorder drüben
und sowas. Das geht hier halt nicht gescheit.
Man sieht beispielsweise auch nicht, wann die
Zertifikate ablaufen. Man bekommt bloß eine
Benachrichtigung, wenn die Zertifikate ablaufen.
Man kann allerdings sich
die Zertifikatinfos irgendwie anschauen.
Frag mich nicht, wo das war.
Ach hier, da.
Ja, das, das sieht man.
Man kann sich dann auch, man kann sich dann auch
die Sachen auskucken.
Genau, das ist was anderes.
Das hat mit Zertifikaten
nichts zu tun. Was ich jetzt halt nicht
sehe, ist
beispielsweise alle meine Domains
schön in einem Graph zusammen
waren die Zertifikate ablaufen.
Also es macht
90% von dem, was ich haben will, allerdings nicht alles.
Und ich glaube,
das hier wird
auch nicht orange,
wenn
die Zertifikate,
das war auch eine Sache, die mich gestört hat.
Mal angenommen,
Zertifikatablauf ist auf 5 Tage runter,
dann wird das hier nicht orange,
sondern wirklich erst, wenn der Check
fehlt schlägt, sondern man kriegt bloß eine
Benachrichtigung.
Es waren ein paar Sachen, die mir
nicht so gefallen haben im Detail.
Also für simple Sachen ist das
wunderbar für daheim.
So, also.
Das ist so für so
Up-Down-Monitor. Wie gesagt, wenn du ein bisschen was
Vorgängreiches haben willst, nimm sowas wie Zappix
oder eines der Nagios-Abkömmlinge.
Ich mag da, ich mag Zappix.
Gerade weil sich Zappix auch gut mit
anderen Sachen integrieren lässt mittlerweile.
Dann die nächste Variante,
was du vielleicht überprüfen willst,
also du musst jetzt mal in den Chat schreiben, was du eigentlich genau
monitoren willst. Die nächste Variante
sind Metriken, zum Beispiel
Performance-Metriken
von deiner Anwendung.
Oder vielleicht auch
von deinem Loadbalancer oder von deinem
Reverse-Proxy oder sowas.
Da kommen wir dann in Richtung
Time-Series-Datenbank
und Prometheus.
Beziehungsweise
Grafana als Visualisierung.
Wenn du zum Beispiel eigene
Anwendungen hast und wissen willst, was die
gerade so intern treiben, wie oft
läuft der Garbage-Collector?
Wie...
Was weiß ich, wie viele User sind eingeloggt?
Wie viele Connections pro Sekunde
und solche Geschichten?
Das kriegst du ja nicht durch eine einfache
Abfrage von ist der Port
Up oder Down raus?
Das heißt, die Software muss das irgendwie
kommunizieren.
Das heißt, die muss das irgendwie exportieren.
Also die Software muss irgendwie
der Umwelt mitteilen und dann brauchst du eine
Software, die diese Information einsammelt.
Und da hat sich eigentlich Prometheus
die letzten Jahre über ziemlich
etabliert.
Prometheus sammelt das ein
und mit Grafana kannst du dann schöne
Dashboards über deine Anwendungsmetriken machen.
Du kannst mit
Prometheus natürlich auch Linux-System
überwachen, weil es gibt einen
Linux Note-Exporter, der
dir so Sachen wie Festplattenbelegung,
CPU-Auslastung und sowas exportiert.
Da hast du aber dann wieder
das Problem, du hast dann ganz super viele
Daten von allen deinen Linux-Systemen.
Dich interessiert dir aber eigentlich nur
in Anführungsstrichen, sagen wir mal,
Festplatte wird voll. Du musst dir
mit Prometheus, wenn du klassisches System
Monitoring machst mit Prometheus,
also dieses klassische
Schwellwert ist überunter, Port
ist Up und Down. Das kannst du mit
Prometheus machen, ist aber ein bisschen
umständlicher. Gerade Port
ist Up oder Down ist ziemlich umständlich.
Du brauchst auch einen extra Exporter, der
die Checks für dich macht und diesen Exporter sammelst
du dann ein. Dann musst du
irgendwie gucken, wo setze ich Schwellwerte,
wie mache ich meine Benachrichtigung.
Das ist in so klassischen Monitoring-System
wie Zappix und so alles mit drin, geht damit
super easy. Ein popliches
Ist der Port Up oder Down in
Prometheus mit einem ordentlichen
Grafana-Dashboard plus
Alerting
ist ziemlich kompliziert versus
wir klicken einfach dreimal auf weiter
und legen den Host an und haben dann
eine Anzeige. Also man merkt
man, das ist nicht wirklich dafür
entworfen worden. Es geht, aber
Du musst
dir das Monitoring mit Prometheus
eher selbst zusammenbauen für solche
klassischen Sachen.
Das nächste, was du hast
ist, was Monitoring angeht, ist
Netzwerk. Netzwerk ist da ein komplett
eigenes Thema, kannst du natürlich auch mit Zappix
und sowas machen. Aber wie gesagt, das geht
meistens über SNMP, da gibt es dann solche Sachen wie
LibreNMS, wobei ich das auch einfach
in Zappix packen würde, wenn ich eh schon Zappix hätte.
Also wenn du Netzwerk-
Infrastruktur überwachen willst, ist das auch nochmal
eine Wissenschaft für sich. Und dann der letzte
Punkt, das ist das, was wir gerade schon hatten,
vielleicht möchtest du auch Logs überwachen
und da bist du dann im Bereich von
Elasticsearch
und
Auditbeat
und Logbeat und
Loki und wie heißt das von
InfluxDB das Zeug?
Keine Ahnung, gibt es auch zig Varianten
für. Also
es steht und fällt damit, lange
kurzer Sinn, was du monitoren
willst, was du am besten dafür
verwendest.
Eigentlich ganz klassisch, Auslastung,
Festplattenbelegung auf einen Blick.
Ja.
Dann
würde ich sowas wie Zappix verwenden.
Du kannst dir auch
Prometheus angucken, ob du damit besser klarkommst,
aber du musst halt da relativ viel
selbst zusammenstöpseln. Du brauchst
beispielsweise
du musst Nordexporter installieren auf allen deinen
Linux Kisten, dann musst du den einsammeln
lassen oder musst du irgendwie dir ein
ordentliches Dashboard dafür bauen und dir
überlegen, wie du dir ein paar Nachrichtungen schickst.
Es ist mit Abstand die
flexibelste Lösung,
aber braucht halt ein bisschen Handarbeit
und man muss vieles sich selbst ausdenken.
Oder du nimmst sowas wie Zappix
oder Checkmk
oder, tja, ganz ehrlich
ups
Hierzu kann ich nicht wirklich
viel sagen, weil ich es noch nie richtig verwendet habe,
aber das gibt es auch.
Also, ich würde wahrscheinlich Zappix
nehmen. Das ist wohl eher
was für Netzwerke. Hab ich auch noch nicht verwendet, aber ich
glaube, das ist was, was
aus Libre oder
Free oder OpenNMS entstanden
ist und das ist hauptsächlich für Netzwerküberwachung
über SNMP.
Du kannst, glaube ich, mit
Agents das auch machen,
aber ich würde wahrscheinlich mir mal
Zappix angucken, wenn es ein bisschen umfangreicher ist.
Also, wenn du nicht nur zwei VMs hast,
ich finde da Zappix ganz gut.
Muss man
sich ein bisschen einarbeiten, bis man das
gepikt hat, aber dann ist
ganz ok.
Und das Schöne an Zappix ist,
Zappix kann mittlerweile auch recht gut
andere Sachen anzapfen. Du kannst den Zappix
auch Prometheus
Nodexporter integrieren. Ein bisschen umständlich
und leider nicht so schön, wie man es gerne
hätte. Die Grafen im Zappix sind jetzt auch nicht
so geil. Das heißt, wenn man wirklich
super advancede Grafen braucht, könnte man
auch ein Grafana noch zusätzlich betreiben.
Ja, Monitoring ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen
komplizierteres Thema und ein eigenes Thema
für sich. Es gibt
ein paar simple Monitoring-Lösungen
sowas wie Uptime, Kuma, da bist du
aber schon über die Grenze von dem, was das
Tool kann, raus, weil du willst
Festplattenbelegung.
Es gibt leider
kein, wie soll man sagen,
so simples,
kompaktes,
bisschen mehr Monitoring-Tool.
Nicht super umfangreich, aber bisschen mehr.
Gibt's leider nicht, ja.
Also ich fänd's ja cool, wenn
irgendwann mal einer was
bauen würde, was so die
Basics abdeckt, bloß ein bisschen
was, was
vielleicht noch eine Übersichtsseite
hätte mit ein bisschen IP-Verwaltung
dabei.
Gibt's, gibt's nicht, aber
vielleicht,
vielleicht habe ich da auch irgendeinen
Denkfehler, dass das gar keinen Sinn macht, ja, kann auch
sein. Ja, also wie gesagt,
steht und fällt damit, was du eigentlich letztendlich
überwachen willst.
So, next. So, wir gucken jetzt mal
fertig.
Prometheus, die Amis finde ich immer am
geilsten, wie sie Prometheus auch aussprechen.
Prometheus.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Wisst ihr, was auch cool ist?
Und was viel einfacher geht, ohne extra
Infrastruktur,
SSH verbinden
und einen Grab machen auf das Logfile?
Ich meine, das ist nicht so wirklich
krasses Web 5.0
Cloud Native oder so,
ja, es skaliert auch nicht diagonal
und to the moon, aber
so eine SSH Verbindung und Grab auf
Logfile funktioniert
in der Regel auch ganz gut.
Jetzt kommen wir tatsächlich mal zu dem Punkt,
woran ich die Infrastruktur der Infrastruktur
verwaltet, sondern wirklich
was benutzt.
Oh, HomeKit.
Was?
Das kenne ich.
Ich habe auch überlegen, das zu verwenden.
Und das
ja, das Linux Desktops.
Mehr RGB.
Heimautomatisierung macht er.
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht.
Okay.
Ach, ich dachte jetzt,
der synchronisiert damit vielleicht seine
Notizen oder so, aber nein, nein.
Der verwaltet damit weiterhin seine Infrastruktur.
Nice.
Ja, toll.
Geil.
Ein Linktree-Klon.
Dafür brauche ich natürlich definitiv
meinen eigenen Kubernetes Cluster.
Das läuft nur im Kubernetes Cluster.
Sowas ist nicht denkbar, woanders
drauf zu hosten.
Ein Url-Shortener muss natürlich
auch unbedingt im Kubernetes Cluster laufen.
Leute, der hat immer noch nichts laufen.
Der hat nichts laufen auf seiner Hardware.
Der hat im Endeffekt
Homebridge,
das ist
eher auf dem Desktop.
Der hat Homebridge,
ein Linktree-Klon
und ein Url-Shortener.
Fertig.
Drei und ein paar statische Web, also
statische Webseiten,
ein Url-Shortener und ein Linktree-Klon.
Warum zum Teufel hat er drei
oder vier Kubernetes Cluster daheim?
Ich mache überhaupt kein internes
CI-CD mehr.
Wenn ich irgendwas habe, dann ist das
wahrscheinlich eh für irgendwas öffentliches
und dann nutze ich GitHub Action.
Das einzige Projekt, wo ich tatsächlich
ein bisschen
was laufen habe, ist das
für das Elektroauto.
Es läuft über GitHub
und das baut ab und zu neue Container
über GitHub Actions
und pusht sie dann.
Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor,
der pusht ein Git Change
und da
passiert einfach nichts.
Da muss er an 800
Stellen gucken.
Was ist jetzt
eigentlich das Problem?
Drei Stunden, drei Stunden,
drei Stunden, Kinder noch einmal drauf.
Er hat sicherlich viel gelernt.
Ich sage nichts.
Das habe ich ganz am Anfang dazu gesagt.
Sollte es rein zu Lernzwecken sein,
vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, nicht mit drei Kubernetes-Clustern daheim.
Ok, es ist im Prinzip
exakt das, was ich vermutet hatte.
Er lässt
die Infrastruktur zum größten Teil
sich selbst verwalten.
Er hat quasi
Infrastruktur, um Infrastruktur
zu verwalten, um Infrastruktur zu haben.
Also
nicht wirklich irgendwas.
Im Prinzip das,
was ich gedacht habe.
Ich lag falsch.
AMD hat ein großes Problem.
Ok, wir haben schon lange kein Video
vom Aura mehr geguckt.
Die sind ja immer gut gemacht.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Was, was, was
erzählt der Bauer zu AMD?
Weil für mich hat sich das eh erledigt.
Ich habe jetzt meinen neuen PC
am Start mit Grafikkanons was.
Da wäre ich bestimmt keine AMD-Karte mehr reinstecken,
die trotzdem schlechter ist.
Oder zumindest, was heißt, schlecht
ist die Performance-Technik schlechter,
Stromverbrauchstechnik schlechter, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Gucken wir mal. Also
der Aura.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen
zu einem weiteren Video. Erstmal
ein kurzes Dankeschön an euch
beim letzten 7900XCX Video,
das wir gemacht haben, wo ich bei einer Karte
die Wärmeleitpaste getauscht habe.
Habt ihr extrem viel kommentiert
und mich dementsprechend dazu verleitet,
dem ganzen nochmal mehr auf den Grund zu gehen.
Deswegen danke für die ganzen Kommentare
an dieser Stelle. Ich habe mich
die ganze Woche mit diesem Thema beschäftigt.
Und es ist definitiv
kontrolliert. Und ich kann jetzt schon
vorwegnehmen, dass es für AMD
auf jeden Fall katastrophal
wird. Also
ich dachte erst, okay, am Anfang im ersten Video
ist es tatsächlich nur ein Problem vielleicht mit
Anpressdruck, Wärmeleitpaste. Hetzter Werbung.
Alles klar. Aber wir gehen
in die Beschreibung. Nach dem letzten Video haben sich
bei mir insgesamt 48 Leute gemeldet
mit dem Hotspot 100 Grad Celsius
Problem. Davon waren 29
horizontal verbaut.
Mit dem was?
Und wenn man das schon mal
19 horizontal
verbaut, 100 Grad Celsius Problem.
Mit dem was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es geht.
Sie haben sich bei mir insgesamt 48 Leute gemeldet
mit dem Hotspot 100 Grad
Celsius Problem. Mit dem Hotspot
100 Grad Celsius Problem. Okay,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was es geht. Ich vermute, die Grafikate
wird zu warm. Davon waren 29
horizontal verbaut,
19 davon vertikal. Und
wenn man das schon mal sieht,
dann muss einem eigentlich schon klar
sein, dass das Problem nicht so einfach zu lösen
sein kann, wie der Kühler zieht
an der Karte irgendwie durch Schwerkraft. Und
deswegen ist der Anpressdruck schlecht.
Das hab ich mir zumindest mal
direkt gedacht. Dann haben
extrem viele davon mir angeboten,
mir ihre Karte zu schicken. Ich hab dann
so ein bisschen aussortiert, um unterschiedlichste
Fälle abdecken zu können. Erstmal vielen Dank an
Robin, Thomas, Christian und
Bastian, von denen ich jetzt vier Karten
hier habe. Drei davon
hab ich quasi abgekauft. Zwei haben eine
RTX 4080 im Austausch bekommen.
Und einer hat eine 70000
XTX in einem anderen Design
als Austausch bekommen. Beziehungsweise bekommen sie
jetzt noch, weil die Karten kamen jetzt erst bei mir an.
Einer davon bekommt einen Wasserkühler
dann auf die Karte gebaut, weil damit
wird das Problem auf jeden Fall gefixt
sein. Hab dann erstmal alle vier Karten
durchbeschriftet. Also das ist
z.B. Karte C,
dass ich da auch nichts irgendwie später
vertausche und immer weiß, ok, welche
Karte ist welche und ich dann auch immer zuordnen
kann, wo wir genau sind,
bei welchem Step vom Testing.
Grundsätzlich alle von den Karten
...
Meine Karte ist weder positiv noch negativ geneigt, glaube ich.
Ich hoffe ich.
Ich habe ja auch den Grafikkarten-Ständer drunter.
Also meine Grafikkarte ist ja so fett.
Man sieht das hier, geil.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Max ist gut.
Hallo Leute.
Also, guck mal, man sieht das ja hier schön.
Meine Grafik hier, guckt mal, da ist ein Ständer.
Und erkennt ihr das, da ist ein Ständer unten an der Grafikkarte.
Hier, guckt da, seht ihr das?
Hier unten.
Hier.
Da ist ein Ständer an der Grafikkarte, dass sie nicht durchhängt hinten.
So weit sind wir schon Leute, du musst Grafikkarten abstützen, dass sie nicht durchhängen.
Man sieht es hier irgendwann noch ein bisschen besser.
Hier.
Hier, guck da unten, hier, da ist das Ständer drunter.
Seht ihr hier?
Schon Wahnsinn, du musst Grafikkarten abstützen heutzutage.
Verschiedliche Szenarien, aber alle das gleiche Problem mit 110 Grad Celsius Hotspot Temperatur.
Also, war schon irgendwo klar, ganz so einfach.
Okay, wir machen mal ein bisschen weiter, ich will noch nicht ganz dahinter stehen.
Als allererstes habe ich alle vier Karten stock getestet, das heißt alle vertikal auf
meiner Testbench, so wie ich das normalerweise mache und ich wollte erst mal quasi das Software
als Problem ausschließen, das heißt ich habe einmal Gaming getestet, Remnant.
Du weißt ja was, wir machen einfach, wir gucken uns einfach das Fazit an, dann weißt du,
worum es geht.
Wir erschießen es für 10 Minuten und dann auch noch mal nach einer Minute, direkt wieder
auf 110 Grad Celsius.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt bin ich mir sicher, dass mangelnder Anpressdruck definitiv nicht mehr
das Problem sein kann, denn mit anderen Schrauben, der anderen Feder auf der Rückseite und so
weiter, das konnte einfach nicht mehr sein.
Also zurück zum Thema Vapor Chamber und wir hatten ja jetzt...
Was für ein Ding?
Rauchkammer?
Jetzt mit dem Washer Mod und auch mit den gekürzten Standoffs.
Oder was ist eine Vapor Chamber?
Immer horizontal getestet, also immer so.
Und jetzt habe ich mich natürlich dann nochmal gefragt, wie hält sich das Ganze dann vertikal,
also das muss man ja auch wieder abdecken, um zu schauen, hat sich da irgendwas verändert
oder nicht.
Aber auch vertikal mit hohem Anpressdruck war...
Das finde ich äußerst praktisch ehrlich gesagt, dieses 12 Volt Dings, 8 Pin Kabel
mit der Anzeige, das finde ich sehr nützlich, das Teil.
Eigentlich das Ergebnis wie vorher.
Anpressdruck wäre mir halt passte, damit komplett auszuschließen.
Ich habe also wieder meinen selbstgebauten horizontalen Teststand verwendet und diesmal
die Karte dabei hingelegt, um also wieder vertikal zu testen.
In diesem Zustand sollte die Karte wieder gute oder zumindest ähnliche Ergebnisse erreichen
wie im ersten Video.
Wir sehen im Chart nach knapp 10 Minuten eine GPU Temperatur von 62 Grad Celsius und eine
Hotspot Temperatur von 86 Grad Celsius.
Das ist zwar nicht toll, aber ein gutes Stück von 110 Grad Celsius entfernt und die Karte
taktet normal.
Lüfter laufen also bei 1750 Umdrehungen.
Ich habe die Karte dann im laufenden Betrieb ganz vorsichtig aufgestellt, um wieder horizontal
zu testen.
Ich habe währenddessen weiterhin aufgezeichnet.
In GPU-Z dauert es ein paar Sekunden und dann sehen wir plötzlich einen Anstieg sowohl
der Lüftergeschwindigkeit als auch der Hotspot Temperatur.
Im Chart zeichnet sich hier ein deutliches Bild ab.
Innerhalb von nur 3 Minuten.
Moment, die Grafikkarte ist, wenn sie normal eingebaut ist, ich meine, so wie sie jetzt
hängt, ist ja quasi die normale Orientierung, wird sie zu heiß.
Das ist schon fail.
3 Minuten steigt die Hotspot Temperatur auf 110 Grad Celsius an.
Die Lüfter laufen auf 2800 Umdrehungen bzw. 100% und trotzdem kann die Karte den Takt
nicht halten.
Hinzu kommt, dass die GPU Temperatur ebenfalls ansteigt und nicht nur die Hotspot Temperatur.
An diesem Punkt könnte man natürlich vermuten, dass der Kühler nicht richtig sitzt und durch
die horizontale Montage der Kühler nach unten gezogen wird und dadurch der Kontakt jetzt
wieder schlechter ist.
Das lässt sich aber relativ einfach ausschließen, denn ich habe die Karte jetzt einfach wieder
hingelegt.
Und jetzt kommt das interessante.
Es verändert sich nichts mehr.
Die Temperaturen bleiben schlecht und es lässt nur eine Erklärung zu.
Die Vapor-Chamber selbst ist das Problem.
Was?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was ist eine Vapor-Chamber?
Gibt es das auch auf Deutsch das Wort vielleicht?
Was soll das sein?
Eine Dampfkammer.
Was?
Was genau hat das jetzt mit Vapor-Chamber?
Ach, die Vapor-Chamber sind quasi das, wo die Kühlrippen durchlaufen oder wie?
Okay, der Kühler, irgendetwas mit dem Kühler.
Der anderen Karten so nochmal komplett durchgetestet, um das Problem auch zu bestätigen und hier
jetzt nochmal als Beispiel das Verhalten der Karte B, die komplett ungeöffnet ist, also
Ausgangszustand von AMD.
Anpressdruck, Wärmeleitpaste dementsprechend unangetastet, die Kurven sind identisch.
Auch hier habe ich nach 10 Minuten die Karte von vertikal auf horizontal gekippt und man
sieht einen sofortigen Anstieg der Hotspot-Temperatur.
Nach weiteren 9 Minuten habe ich die Karte wieder zurück gekippt, aber die Perf- Wie
kann das sein, dass AMD sowas nicht merkt?
Beziehungsweise, vielleicht haben sie es gemerkt, dann habe ich gedacht, scheiß drauf.
Performance bleibt weiterhin schlecht.
Das heißt, Problem komplett eingegrenzt und zwar auf den Kühler bzw. die Vapor-Chamber
selbst.
Die Vapor-Chamber ist nichts anderes als eine riesige flache Heatpipe, das bedeutet wir
haben da drin eine Flüssigkeit und wir haben in der Regel einen abgesenkten Innendruck
und durch den Innendruck kann man eben steuern, an welchem Punkt die Flüssigkeit verdampfen
soll.
Dadurch, dass dann die Flüssigkeit verdampft, z.B. im GPU-Bereich, kondensiert die wieder
am kalten Bereich, also dann unter den Finnen und dann kann das wieder zurücklaufen zum
heißen Bereich und so entsteht quasi eine Zirkulation, also einen Kreislauf zwischen
verdampfen und kondensieren, der dann das ermöglicht, die Karte zu kühlen.
Die Menge an Flüssigkeit- Okay, das hätte man am Anfang erzählen können,
ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es eben gab, was eine Vapor-Chamber ist, aber gut, das ist
interessant.
Es ist nur eine Milliliter, also es ist wirklich wenig und man muss es eben perfekt auslegen
zwischen dem Innendruck, den man hat, der Menge an Flüssigkeit, dem Volumen usw. und
natürlich auch dem Geflecht, das sich innen in der Vapor-Chamber befindet, was dann eben
durch die Kapillarwirkung dann erlaubt, dass die Flüssigkeit wieder zum heißen Bereich
zurückbewegen kann.
Exzellent.
Leute, IQ 5 Punkte gestiegen heute Morgen schon wieder.
Das bedeutet, es gibt eigentlich nur zwei mögliche Ursachen bei der Vapor-Chamber selber,
also entweder ist sie nicht richtig ausgelegt, d.h. irgendwas passt vom Innendruck nicht
oder von der Menge an Flüssigkeit, die drin ist, oder wir haben einfach einen kapitalen
Konstruktionsfehler bei der Vapor-Chamber selber, was wahrscheinlich, oder was die wahrscheinlichere
Variante ist.
Denn wir sehen ja auch, die Vapor-Chamber ist dies nicht symmetrisch, die hat eine relativ
komplexe Struktur hier hinten und es ist naheliegend, dass in eben der einen Ausrichtung das Wasser
nicht mehr ausreichend zurückfließen kann zu der GPU und damit die Vapor-Chamber an sich
kapituliert.
Durch das Verhalten, das wir sehen, mit diesem Kippen und Zurückkippen, das es eben dann
schlecht bleibt, ist auch auszuschließen, dass es z.B. die Oberfläche der Vapor-Chamber
ist, also es liegt nicht daran, dass hier irgendwie was uneben ist oder sowas, das ist
absolut nicht der...
Aber es ist schon blöd, wenn die Grafikkarte in der normalen Montage-Position überhitzt,
das ist schon ziemlicher Müll, das ist schon ziemlicher Dreck, den AMD da gebaut hat.
Ich meine, das müssen sie doch gemerkt haben.
Das ist nicht der Fall, sondern es ist einfach nur die Vapor-Chamber selbst.
Ich hatte jetzt leider nicht mehr die Zeit, das Ding aufzumachen und zu schauen, ob innen
drin irgendwie ein Materialfehler vorliegt oder ob es einfach ein Konstruktionsfehler
an sich ist, aber das ändert an der Tatsache nichts, dass der Kühler das Problem ist und
das ist natürlich jetzt für AMD, ich kann sagen, wie es ist, ein riesen Desaster, denn
man kann sagen, wie es ist, die ganzen MBA-Karten, also sag ich mal, dieses Referenzdesign von
AMD hier, die sind davon betroffen, zum großen Teil, also nicht alle davon, es gibt ja auch
Karten, die funktionieren gut, aber allein, dass mich 48 Leute angeschrieben haben...
Aber warum merken die das nicht?
...Problem haben zeigt, dass das ein riesen Problem ist, das bedeutet auch, das betrifft
auch alle Partnerkarten, das heißt alle, die das MBA-Design haben, sei das jetzt eine Sapphire-Karte,
eine Power-Color-Karte, ASRock, was es alles gibt, alle, die dieses Design benutzen, die
diesen Kühler haben, tendenziell ein riesen Problem, also ich weiß auch nicht, wie AMD
da vorgehen will, man kann jetzt natürlich überlegen, ob man dann wartet, bis die Kunden
eine RMA machen, was aus meiner Sicht bei dem Umfang des Problems auf jeden Fall der
falsche Weg wäre und ich würde mal vermuten, das einzige, was hier übrig bleibt, ist ein
kompletter Rückruf der kompletten MBA-Serie und das betrifft dann eben nicht nur die 7000...
Ja, witzig AMD, aber Freude.
...Sondern auch die XT-Karten.
Wenn man dachte, das Problem bei NVIDIA mit den Kabeln ist ein Problem, dann kann ich
euch sagen, das hier ist ein richtiges Problem, weil bei den NVIDIA-Karten z.B., da waren
das ja, da waren das fünf Fälle von irgendwie 100.000 Karten, hier sind das tausende Fälle,
das ist ja...
Tausende Fälle von tausenden Karten.
...Das Ausmaß, das dieses Problem hier hat, das kann man gar nicht fassen, also, ja, ich
bin froh, dass ich jetzt nach dieser Riesenzeit eingrenzen konnte durch dieses Hin- und Herkippen,
so einfach das klingt, aber sich Stück für Stück daran zu testen und dann wirklich alles
auszuschließen und nur noch dieses Ding als Problem übrig zu haben, ja, hat mir mal wieder
trotzdem Spaß gemacht, auch wenn das jetzt für AMD weniger spaßig wird, weil der finanzielle
Schaden so eine komplette Serie zurückzurufen oder wie auch immer das AMD handhaben möchte,
das wird sicher nicht so toll werden.
Da gibt es wahrscheinlich dann gleich morgen eine Runde Krisen-Meeting bei AMD, wobei ganz
ehrlich, das gibt es nicht gleich morgen, das ist ja Blödsinn, das wissen die doch
schon, das wussten die wahrscheinlich vorher schon, kann doch nicht sein, dass das Ding
komplett durch die Lappen geht, oder, die müssen doch ihren Kram auch im größeren
Stil ausprobieren.
Übrigens auch daran denken, wie AMD Marketing damals Nvidia gebasht hat mit dem Stecker,
sollte man sich als Firma in so einer Größe vielleicht überlegen, ob man sich zu solchen
Aussagen hinreißen lässt, wenn man dann selber solche Probleme hat, betrifft jetzt natürlich
auch Nvidia, auch an eurer Stelle würde ich mich jetzt nicht aus dem Fenster lehnen und
irgendwas zu AMD sagen, aber krasser Fehler von AMD, aus meiner Sicht Vapor Chamber, entweder
Konstruktionsfehler oder Materialfehler, aber riesen Problem bei diesen Karten.
Damit ist das Thema aus meiner Sicht geklärt, ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen, machts gut
bis zum Ende.
Ich wünsche euch viel Zeit, siehste, Leute, gut, dass ich doch viel zu viel Geld ausgegeben
habe für eine 4090, die bleibt wenigstens schön kühl, die war viel zu teuer, ich hätte
mir davon wahrscheinlich zwei AMD oder drei AMD Karten kaufen können, aber gut, da hätte
ich auch nicht die Leistung für gekriegt.
Wie häufig gab es Krisen-Mittings bei deinem noch jetzigen Arbeitgeber?
Das ist schwer zu sagen, also das schwankt immer ein bisschen, je nachdem wenn es Probleme
gibt, also okay, sagen wir so richtig extreme Krisen-Dinger, auch mit Leuten aus dem Urlaub,
zurückordern und so, das gab es in den letzten Jahren einmal, aber Krisen-Meetings in Form
von irgendwas ist kaputt gegangen und das gibt es natürlich öfters, aber so richtig
Krise, das wirklich krass am Arsch war, einmal, einmal die letzten Jahre über, das ist mir
egal, das ist kein Thema, wenn mir es da nicht gefällt, dann muss ich ja da nicht bleiben,
dass es IT-technisch überall an jeder Ecke neue Jobs gibt, habe ich ja zur Zeit gemerkt,
aber es spricht alles dafür, dass es da eigentlich ganz nice ist.
Kafana-Board für Chat-EQ, ja auf geht's.
Also was bei mir, beim jetzigen Arbeitgeber und ich vermute mal auch beim neuen, da weiß
ich noch nicht, was da öfters passiert ist, nicht Krisen-Meetings in Form von jetzt werden
alle einbestellt und es ist wirklich irgendwie eine unternehmenskritische Sache oder so,
jedes Mal wenn was kaputt geht, wird sich das im Nachhinein halt noch angeguckt, was ist
denn passiert, was ist denn gewesen, das ist auch eine Sache, die mir bei meinem aktuellen
Arbeitgeber ein bisschen auf den Keks geht, dass so Retrospektiven eigentlich nicht wirklich
dafür benutzt werden, um jetzt zu gucken, okay was war denn und was können wir denn
verbessern, sondern eher so ein bisschen dazu benutzt werden, so nach dem Motto, wem können
wir es denn in die Schuhe schieben, ja genau, wem kann man es in die Schuhe schieben und
da kommt dann meistens nix Sinnvolles bei raus, wird leider auch noch ein bisschen unterstrichen
dadurch, dass oftmals Leute diese Meetings einberufen und leiten müssen, die von der
Materie so gar keine Ahnung haben und obwohl man ihnen genau sagt, was jetzt wie wo ablauftechnisch
gewesen ist, schreiben sie dann trotzdem was falsches hin und sowas, aber nicht mal absichtlich,
sondern einfach weil sie keine Ahnung von der Thematik haben, die sind richtig lost
bei sowas, tja und ansonsten Krisen Meetings ist was kaputt, man wird angerufen, so nach
dem Motto hier, weißt du was dazu, das kommt natürlich schon öfters mal vor, ja ich mein,
wir haben so viele Systeme, da gehen öfters mal was kaputt, allein schon durch die pure
Anzahl ist da mal irgendwo immer mal was und jeder tut natürlich bei seinem System als
es der Weltuntergang wäre, wenn jetzt gerade dieses System kaputt ist, am geilsten war
immer noch, ich hab irgendwann mal in unser E-Mail Postfach geguckt, also in ein altes
E-Mail Postfach, was eigentlich überhaupt nicht mal verwendet wurde, also reingeguckt
und irgendwann hab ich da mal gesehen, da kam ne Mail rein, das System steht nicht zur
Verfügung, dann hab ich mir gedacht, weißt du was, ich bin jetzt einfach mal nett und
antworte da drauf, dass das eigentlich komplett die falsche Stelle ist und selbst wenn das
die richtige Stelle wäre, es unklar ist, was das System ist, also welches System es geht
oder kam dann als Antworter drauf, ja das System mit dem wir täglich arbeiten, Ausrufezeichen
und hab ich mir gedacht, ok, dann kümmere ich mich jetzt da doch nicht drum, das System
das ist einfach zu erklären, das ist der Unterschied zwischen Theorie und Wirklichkeit, auch wenn
du Systeme redundant ausgelegt hast, können die durchaus Probleme haben, auch wenn du
es natürlich so baust, dass du möglichst wenig Probleme haben wirst, aber gegen irgendwelche
Bugs oder schlicht ergreifend Fehler, kannst du auch mit nem redundanten System manchmal
nichts machen, wenn jetzt einer zum Beispiel neue Softwareversion deploit und auch wenn
schön getestet wurde und sowas und es wird dann festgestellt, oh Mist, nehmen wir ein
praktisches Beispiel, praktisches Beispiel, was im Vorfeld keiner wirklich gemerkt hat
und zwar, also wirklich so aus der Realität jetzt, eins zu eins so passiert, wo dir alle
redundanten Systeme nichts gebracht haben, also wir haben ne App für unsere Außendienstmitarbeiter
auf dem Smartphone, was die mit der App machen können ist eigentlich relativ egal, ehrlich
gesagt ich weiß es gar nicht genau, was die da mit machen können, aber es gibt ne App
für alle Außendienstmitarbeiter, ja Chuck, danke schon für den Sub und eines Tages
ging die App nicht mehr, konnte sie nicht mehr connecten, warum, tja, man wusste es
erstmal nicht, die haben mich auch dann morgens angerufen, wir hätten doch nachts irgendwas
gemacht, aber ich hab doch mit euren komischen App nichts zu tun, so und ich erspare euch
jetzt mal das ganze Gerate, wisst ihr was es gewesen ist, ein Zertifikat und zwar folgender
Zusammenhang, wir haben unsere Zertifikate erneuert, weil Zertifikate abgelaufen werden
in ungefähr, keine Ahnung, 8, 9, 10 Tagen, was haben wir gemacht, wir haben ein neues
letztes Encrypt Zertifikat geholt und haben das eingespielt und darauf hin, mit bisschen
Verzögerung aber darauf hin ging dann halt die App nicht mehr und was ist gewesen, das
Zertifikat und zwar alles gültig, überhaupt gar kein Problem, die App hat Zertifikat
Pinning betrieben, also die haben quasi geguckt, dass das Zertifikat von einem ganz speziellen
Herausgeber sein muss und die haben nicht mitbekommen, dass wir jetzt und das schon seit bestimmt
3 Jahren Let's Encrypt verwenden, ihr Zertifikat lief halt eine ganze Weile und das war noch
von einem anderen Aussteller und jetzt gab es da halt auch, wie seit 2, 3 Jahren für
alle Services ein Let's Encrypt Zertifikat, war überhaupt kein Ding, nur die App, die
hat halt gesagt, ne, Let's Encrypt vertraue ich nicht, ich vertraue nur diesem einen Aussteller
und dann ging die Verbindung nicht mehr, was haben wir gemacht, ja wir haben das alte Zertifikat
wieder eingespielt, das war ja noch gültig für irgendwie ein paar Tage und die mussten
ihre App updaten und das war auch so ein Meeting, das hat auch so ein bisschen untermauert,
dass ich da weg muss und zwar, ich hab gesagt in diesem Meeting, dass wir aber, also wir
können das Zertifikat jetzt austauschen, ist ja sinnvoll, machen wir, wir sollten bloß
nicht vergessen, auch Planungstechnik, wir sollten bloß nicht vergessen, dass in 7 oder
8 Tagen das Zertifikat abläuft und wenn dieses Zertifikat in 7 Tagen noch nicht getauscht
ist, dann kann der komplette Außendienst nicht verarbeiten, ich wollte das bloß mal
sagen, dass das allen die Tragweite dieser Zertifikatsachen bewusst ist und dann kam
irgend so ein Management Typ an und meinte, ah das ist doch jetzt egal, wir haben doch
jetzt die Probleme und nicht in 7 Tagen, ich war wirklich kurz davor irgendwie ihn zu erzählen
so nach dem Motto, dann weint nicht rum, das nächste Mal wenn es kaputt geht, ich hab
da glaube ich irgendwas gesagt, dann sollte man sich im Nachhinein nicht beschweren,
ich wollte es bloß sagen und es wurde ja wirklich ganz ganz auf den letzten Drücker noch getauscht
oder so, ja siehste, Dutti, daran siehst du selbst wenn was redundant ausgelegt ist,
es gibt immer Fälle, da kannst du nichts machen, wichtig ist, dass du im Nachhinein dir das
anguckst und dir vielleicht überlegst, an welcher Stelle ist uns das durch die Lappen
gegangen, also an welcher Stelle hätten wir es denn merken können und wenn du halt solche
Retrospektiven eher Richtung wer ist denn jetzt der böse machst, dann verbesserst
du halt nichts, das ist das was bei uns ganz gerne dann passiert, also sprich diese Besprechung
wäre dann eher dazu benutzt zu gucken, wem kann man jetzt die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben,
aber weniger so nach dem Motto, was könnten wir denn machen und diesen Fehler abzufangen
im Vorfeld ist gar nicht mal so einfach, also an welcher Stelle soll sowas festgestellt
werden, das hat ja nichts mit der App an sich zu tun, die verbugt ist, es hat auch nichts
mit irgendwelchen fachlichen Tests zu tun, die dann fehlenschlagen, also dieses Problem
das muss also quasi fast schon einmal auftreten, dass man nur weiß, dass es existiert, um
sich dann zu überlegen, an welcher Stelle fackelt man es ab, ey das dürfen die ja,
aber dann sollen sie sich danach nicht beschweren und das ist das, wo ich auch schon öfters
Diskussionen hatte und angeeckt bin, weil genau das eben passiert ist, dass man im Vorfeld
entweder, entweder hat man im Vorfeld gesagt, ja wir nehmen die Probleme in Kauf, obwohl
man darauf hingewiesen wurde und dann sind die Probleme gekommen, da wollte man nichts
mehr wissen oder eben halt sowas, wie ich eben erzählt habe, ja Manager, die nicht
managen können, haben wir leider jede Menge, es gibt durchaus fähige Manager, habe ich
auch ein paar erlebt, aber ich habe da irgendwie mittlerweile schon so ein bisschen ein Gespür,
mal gucken, ob sich das bewahrheitet, ja wenn ich das jetzt mal die Welt bei einem anderen
Arbeitgeber sehe, ich bin jetzt ja schon lange da, ich habe da mittlerweile schon ein gewisses
Gespür dafür, also wenn manche Leute oder welche Manager was hinbekommen und welche
nicht, also nicht nur von den Leuten, wo ich weiß, ok bei denen klappt das meistens,
sondern auch die Herangehensweise ist irgendwie, weiß ich, also ich versuche das mal irgendwie
zu erklären, also es gibt Leute, die versuchen, ok das ist eine gute Frage, das kann ich
damit, also wir müssen uns jetzt mal ein bisschen unterscheiden, Manager Richtung Projektmanagement
oder Richtung Teammanagement und Führungskraft, das sind jetzt mal unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe,
also zum Beispiel Manager, die wissen, dass ihr Plan nicht eins zu eins so in der Realität
funktionieren wird, das sind meistens welche, wo es gut funktioniert, so blöd das klingt,
also es gibt da so zwei, könnte man so sagen, natürlich ist immer ganz viele Zwischenschritte
möglich, aber es gibt so zwei Herangehensweisen, die ich gesehen habe, Leute, die irgendwelche
Projekte managen, du hast einmal die, die quasi der Meinung sind, wenn was negatives,
oder wenn was, was heißt, ok es gibt einmal die Leute, die der Meinung sind, wenn du auf
Probleme hinweist, das wäre was negatives, und das ist so ein bisschen bei Facebook und
Meta aktuell, so nach dem Motto, die Leute sollen irgendeinen Scheiß entwickeln, den
sie nie im Leben verwenden werden wollen, sonst wie, weil es ihr fucking Job ist und
die Manager erzählen ihnen dann, wie könnt ihr unser Produkt nicht lieben, ihr müsst
es lieben und benutzen und nur dann wird es gut, so nach dem Motto, du glaubst ja nicht
an unsere Vision und ihr macht das ja nur schlecht, so Leute, gibt es überall, also
sprich, dass du, wenn du auf potenzielle Probleme hinweist, dass das als was negatives gesehen
wird, die gibt es und das sind die, wo es meistens nicht klappt, jetzt Projekttechnisch
und Live Services, Live Schalten, bei denen klappt das meistens nicht, die erstellen Pläne
im Voraus, die oftmals wenig mit der Realität zu tun haben, weil, naja, wenn du nicht auf
Probleme hingewiesen werden darfst, als Manager weißt du das selbst nicht, die erstellen
zwar äußerst detailreiche Pläne und alles, allerdings enthalten diese Pläne halt meistens
dann nicht die problematischen Sachen, weil Probleme darf man ja nicht erzählen und die
sind auch sehr von ihrer, von ihrem eigenen Management-Skill überzeugt, so nach dem Motto,
wenn ich den Plan gemacht habe, dann muss der Stur befolgt werden, weil das ist der
perfekte Plan, so nach dem Motto, so, das sind die, das sind die Sorten Manager, also
gerade Projektmanager, wo ich gesehen habe, da klappt das nicht so richtig, bei denen,
wo das klappt, und das sind auch witzigerweise die, von denen ich zumindest, wo ich weiß,
was die so verdienen, die tatsächlich anscheinend irgendwie eine Erfolgsprämie oder so haben,
keine Ahnung, weil die verdienen in der Regel mehr und bei denen klappt das dann auch ganz
gut, das ist bestimmt, bestimmt ist das irgendwie ein bisschen an Erfolg gekoppelt, wäre hier
auch blöd, ganz ehrlich, woran willst du Projektmanager-Gehälter bzw.
Manager-Sachen denn koppeln, am sinnvollsten natürlich an Projekte funktionieren, nach
dem du sie gemanagt hast, zumindest die Sorte Manager, wo das funktioniert, das sind welche,
die sich durchaus anhören, wenn man Bedenken hat oder Probleme sieht, die allerdings das
nicht überdramatisieren, also du kannst von ausgehen, wenn neue Sachen eingeführt werden,
Techniker werden dir quasi von morgens bis abends erzählen, was da dran Kacke ist und
dass es schlecht ist und dass es da nicht dran gedacht wurde, dass dieser Fall nicht
getestet wird, also im Prinzip erzählen dir quasi Leute den ganzen Tag, dass irgendwas
nicht funktionieren wird, aber es ist wichtig, sich das anzuhören und sich wichtig rauszufiltern
als Manager, ok, was klingt denn da jetzt irgendwie zu kostennutzenrelevant, also sprich,
wir müssen, also sprich, wenn dir eine Techniker erzählt, nach drei Jahren Entwicklungszeit
und eine Woche bevor die Anwendung live geht, die Anwendung ist grundsätzlich beschissen,
die alte war besser und das neue wird nicht funktionieren, alles Crap, dann kannst du
sagen, ok, Mist, wir blasen alles ab und entwickeln die Anwendung neu, das ist ja natürlich unrealistisch,
kannste nicht machen, ist auch recht unwahrscheinlich, dass das wirklich so eintreten wird, so unspezifisch
wie das ist, aber wenn dir jemand erzählt, wir hatten letztens Probleme mit dem Zertifikat
da und da und ich glaube in der neuen Anwendung ist das auch nicht berücksichtigt, dann sollte
man sich das vielleicht mal überlegen, so nach dem Motto, ja, mal gucken, ok, lass
mal noch ein paar Entwickler einladen, ist das denn wirklich so, also die Manager, die
sich Probleme anhören und die irgendwie einfließen lassen in den Ablauf und die die gleichermaßen
wissen, dass ihr Plan nie 100% Bestand haben wird, wenn es denn wirklich dann losgeht,
was denn eigentlich die, wo es am besten klappt, mir hat mal einer von unseren Managern, von
denen ich den Eindruck habe, dass die Sachen ganz gut klappen, wenn er sie macht, der hat
mal sinngemäß sowas gesagt, wie, wenn du einen Plan für alles hast, dann brauchst
du auch keinen Manager, klingt natürlich ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ich gehe mal davon
aus, was er meint ist und da muss ich ihm an der Stelle auch recht geben, was ich bis
jetzt gesagt habe, also, was er meint ist, nicht, dass du nicht Sachen planen solltest,
sondern, dass es in der Realität eh immer ein bisschen anders kommt, ja, du hast zwar
irgendwelche Ablaufpläne, du planst eine halbe Stunde dafür ein, du planst eine Stunde
dafür ein, dafür und danach soll dieser Schritt passieren und sowas, es passiert immer irgendwas,
was nicht sein sollte, ja, oder manche Sachen gehen viel schneller als gedacht, dafür sind
andere Sachen, du hast an der Stelle, wird dann festgestellt, ach Mist, da liegt ja gar
nicht das richtige WLAN am Switch an, da hat ja noch keiner dran gedacht, Mist, Datenbank
ist erst eine Stunde später verfügbar und sowas in der Richtung und dann muss ein guter
Manager in der Lage sein und dafür ist er ein Manager und dafür ist er da und nur dafür
ist er, kriegt er massig Kohle an der Stelle auch, dann muss er in der Lage sein, diesen
Plan so anzupassen, dass er weiter funktioniert, aber diesen einen Fall berücksichtigt, ohne
dass alles komplett abkackt, dafür ist ein guter, der muss das managen, der muss nicht
im Vorfeld Pläne machen, die 100% wasserdicht sind, ein Manager muss managen können und
das ist das, was unglaublicherweise viele Manager nicht können und ja, das sind so diese
zwei Typen an Manager, die ich gesehen habe bei uns, sind diese Richtung, wo das geht
und ja und dort wo es klappt und dort wo es nicht klappt, ach ja und die größten Dummschwerzer
sind meistens auch die, wo lustigerweise wo es nicht klappt, also derjenige, der mir erzählt
hat so nach dem Motto, Achtung, wir haben jetzt ein Problem, nicht in 7 Tagen, das ist auch
jemand, der sonst wenig auf die Reihe kriegt, wo auch sonst vieles nicht klappt, wo hingegen
der andere von diesem Plan, der auch diesen Spruch gebracht hat, hier mit Manager, wenn
alles klappt, dann brauchst du keinen Manager, bei dem klappt das besser, die Sachen, da
gehen auch Sachen in die Hose, aber im Endeffekt, zum größten Teil klappt das ganz gut.
Ja und was für mich ein guter Manager ausmacht, du meinst wahrscheinlich, was ein guter Chef
ausmacht in dem Fall, oder, also was ein guter Manager ausmacht, hab ich jetzt ja mehr oder
weniger erzählt, was, viele Leute sehen ja auch, also Manager, Synonym für Vorgesetzter,
Teamleiter, sehe ich, würde ich tatsächlich ein bisschen unterscheiden, so ist es Projektmanagement,
ist es irgendwelche andere, oder ist es eben quasi Teamleitung oder sowas, das sind ja
schon, sind zwar auch Manager, aber sind ein bisschen anders gelagert, also so ein Projekt
von irgendeiner Software Einführung oder irgendwie einem Netzwerk Umbau oder so, ist
was anderes, wie, du bist quasi Teamleiter, tja, was ist für mich als guter Team, was
als guter Manager bzw. als guter Vorgesetzter, guter Teamleiter wichtig, also, ich glaube,
eine ganz entscheidende Sache, was auch vielen fehlt, die Fähigkeit dazu, ist, die, die
zwei Welten oder mehrere Welten zusammenzubringen, und zwar, wenn sich Chef, Vorstand, Abteilung,
was auch immer, sich irgendwas ausdenken, dann muss das in relativ ungefilterter und,
und, ja, mit möglichst, mit möglichst hohem, so Wahrheitsgehalt bei denen ankommen, die
es umsetzen sollen, und umgedreht, wenn es irgendwelche Probleme gibt, da müssen die
auch relativ realitätsgetreu weiter oben ankommen, dass man da richtig drauf reagieren
kann, und was ich gesehen habe ist, dort aktuell, wo ich arbeite, dass das nicht funktioniert,
also sprich, mal angenommen, der oberste Oberchef denkt sich irgendwie super neue Sachen aus,
die Vision für 2040 oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas, das mag auch durchaus alles Hand und Fuß
haben, was der sich da ausdenkt, das Problem ist nur, dass das, was davon bei einem ankommt,
keinen Sinn mehr ergibt, weil es durch fünf Filterschichten gelaufen ist, die das irgendwie
transformiert haben, und umgedreht, wenn du irgendwelche grundsätzlichen Problemen,
Probleme siehst in der Firma, und sprichst die an, und das durch fünf Filterschichten
oder durch zwei, drei Filterschichten, sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, es ist mal was, nur
auf IT-Ebene, durch drei, vier Filterschichten wieder nach oben bringst, und jede Filterschicht
lässt davon das weg, was sie vielleicht auch nur im Entferntesten irgendwie im schlechten
Licht dastehen lassen könnte, dann bleibt halt manchmal nicht viel übrig, weil dein
Teamleiter filtert das weg, was vielleicht negativ auf sein Team zurückfallen könnte,
der Gruppenleiter oder Resorleiter oder was auch immer es da drüber gibt, filtert das
weg, was für seine Untergruppen negativ sein könnte, was ja schon viel mehr sind, da kommt
der Abteilungsleiter, der filtert nochmal weg, was für seine Abteilung negativ sein
könnte, und dann kriegt es der Ober-IT-Typ und denkt sich, wo ist jetzt eigentlich das
Problem, die sollen sich mal nicht so anstellen, weil eigentlich nix übrig geblieben ist,
also das ist eines der wichtigsten Sachen, die ein Vorgesetzter braucht, generell in
so leitenden Positionen, die müssen mehrere Welten zusammenbringen können, man muss wissen,
was umgesetzt werden soll, man muss das verstehen, was man sich dabei gedacht hat, das ist ja
oftmals der Witz, also man muss verstehen, wie, warum wollen die das eigentlich machen,
damit man dahinter kommt, was überhaupt die Richtung ist, in die das gehen soll, ja,
es ist ja oftmals nicht nur damit getan, dass jemand zu dir sagt, hey, also es ist nicht
so, dass der IT-Chef jetzt sagt, installiere mir mal drei Web-Server, das wird er nicht
sagen, der wird sagen, unsere Vision für 2023 ist bla bla bla XY-Service für sowieso anzubieten,
das ist darauf resultiert, dein Team muss drei Web-Server installieren, da hat er keine
Ahnung von, muss er ja auch nicht, aber du musst trotzdem wissen, was ist denn der größere
Zusammenhang dahinter, also wofür sind denn diese drei Web-Server, vielleicht machst
du ja dann beim Aufsetzen Sachen anders, weil du weißt, ah, das muss ich ja in dieses
Gesamtbild einfügen, das muss man schon verstehen, also das müssen Vorgesetzte können, das kriegen
viele nicht auf die Reihe, das ist in beide Richtungen wichtig, das weiter zu kommunizieren,
und was auch wichtig ist, dass es Vorgaben gibt, auf die man sich verlassen kann, also
sprich, wenn heute einer sagt, hey, wir haben ein Ticketsystem und unsere Vorstellung ist,
dass Tickets quasi auf diese Art und Weise bearbeitet werden, dann ist es wichtig, dass
man sich darauf verlassen kann, dass nicht zwei Wochen später einer sagt, hey, warum
hast du dieses Häkchen im Ticket nicht gemacht, das weiß man noch mittlerweile, dass das gemacht
werden soll, und du denkst dir, hä, habt ihr nicht vor zwei Wochen noch was anderes erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, dieses Feature ist nur eingebaut für die Abteilung, wir sollen
es gar nicht verwenden, so hä, was denn jetzt, also das ist wichtig, dass irgendwie die Sachen
klar sind, wie was gemacht wird, und wenn man es so macht, wie das kommuniziert wurde,
dass danach keiner sagen kann, du hast es verkehrt gemacht und hättest es besser wissen
müssen, weil es ist nicht dein Job, das zu wissen, es ist der Job deines Chefs, dir
das zu sagen, oder zumindest die Stelle, die sich das ausgedacht hat, soweit bekannt zu
machen, dass es jeder wissen kann, genauso wenig wie es der Job deines Chefs ist, im
Webserver zu installieren, das kriegen auch einige nicht hin, also es muss gewisse, das
ist auch was, was mich immer ein bisschen aufregt, wenn man im Vorfeld sagt, wir müssen jetzt
in drei Monaten XYZ umgezogen haben, wir wissen, dass es dabei zu Problemen kommen wird, aber
das ist so wichtig, wir nehmen die Probleme in Kauf, wenn die auftreten, der Zeitplan
ist uns halt so wichtig, und wenn es Probleme gibt, dann treten die halt auf, so, dann treten
die Probleme auf, und dann sagen die Leute dann, was, ihr hättet ja nochmal gesagt,
dass es zu Problemen kommen kann, die Probleme nehmen wir natürlich nicht in Kauf, das regt
mich dann immer auf, mal ihr Dummschwätze, das einzige, was an diesen Positionen ist,
was die sich da denken ist, oh fuck, das könnte jetzt ja negativ auf mich zurückfallen, vorher
sind das ungelegte Eier, vorher sind das ungelegte Eier, weil das sind abstrakte Probleme, oder
sagt irgendjemand, das könnte Probleme geben, ach was, es gibt ja noch gar kein Problem,
so lange es kein Problem gibt, tschau, es mir das egal, und dann gibt es eins, dann sagt
man, nee, das geht jetzt natürlich nicht, das sind so Leute, die versuchen sich einfach
so durchzumogeln, deswegen ist es wichtig, wenn man in solchen Unternehmen arbeitet,
wo es öfters vorkommt, manchmal Protokolle sich durchlesen von irgendwelchen übergreifenden
Kunden, das mache ich teilweise ganz gerne, und wenn es so Entscheidungen gibt, man bekommt
da mit der Zeit so ein gewisses Gespür dafür, so welche Aussagen, die jetzt getroffen wurden,
höchstwahrscheinlich nochmal relevant sind, sich aufschreiben, wann was gesagt wurde,
weil dann können sie sich nicht mehr rausreden, es ist schlimm, es doof, dass sowas notwendig
ist, aber das ist auch was, was ich an Führungskräften mies finde, ist, wenn Führungskräfte unter
selektivem Gedächtnisverlust leiden, so nach dem Motto, das hab ich nie gesagt, oder das
wurde so nie kommuniziert, das ist deswegen immer gut, wenn man dann sagen kann, doch,
auf der Teamrunde vor zwei Wochen wurde genau das gesagt, da können sich dann immer schlecht
wieder rausreden, weil du hast ja dann auch mehr Leute, die sich auch dran erinnern,
und vielleicht findest du sogar noch das Protokoll, wo irgendwie ansatzweise was dazu
drinne steht, also selektiver Gedächtnisverlust bei Führungskräften ist auch immer so ein
Problem.
So, genug dazu.
Wenn du einem Manager einen Tipp gibt, ey, Alter, das klingt wie ne Frage von der Personalabteilung
in nem Vorstellungsgespräch, wenn du einem, wenn du deinem Angehenden, oder wenn du einem
Angehenden einen Tipp geben könntest, welcher wäre das, das klingt einzeln wie ne Frage
aus nem Vorstellungsgespräch, das könnt ich mir vorstellen, das könnte man genau
eins zu eins dort fragen, ja, ich hab da jetzt schon genug zugesagt, keine Ahnung, war bestimmt
die eine oder andere Sachen dabei, also ich finde, ich finde man muss es nicht übertreiben,
also man muss nicht, man muss nicht wirklich für jede Besprechung Protokoll machen, das
ist wirklich Overkill, gerade wenn du sagst, hey lass uns mal hier irgendwie xy schnell
zusammen angucken mit drei Leuten, da brauchst du kein Protokoll dafür, aber wenn das so
Sachen sind, wo so relevante, relevante Infos geshared werden, da ist es tatsächlich nicht
verkehrt, ja, natürlich, das ist wieder typischer Fall von meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber halt,
wo so Vorstellungen und Wirklichkeit weiter auseinander liegen, warum ich hier ins Management
gehe, weil ich mir den Scheiß nicht geben will, das ist wirklich der letzte Job, den
ich machen will, das ist ja auch nicht einfach, es ist wirklich nicht einfach, das ordentlich
zu machen, es ist stressig, gerade unteres Management ist stressig, unteres Management
ist, du kriegst, ich sag mal Teamleiter zum Beispiel, du kriegst permanent Einlauf von
deinen Chefs und du kriegst permanent Gemäckere von deinen und Anschiss von deinen Leuten,
in alle Richtungen, du wirst eigentlich von allen Seiten nur angekackt, als Teamleiter,
als Teamleiter ist eigentlich echt undankbare Position, irgendwas kann man wahrscheinlich
noch sagen, ja, so, ähm, das hab ich vergessen, was ich vorher noch sagen wollte, egal, ich
wollte was zu Protokoll, ach ja, ach ja, da gibt es bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber auch
so ein, ja, so ein Trend und zwar, seiner Weile, seit Jahren schon, hat sich etabliert,
dass man für Teamrunden und solche Sachen Protokolle anfertigt, ist ja auch sinnvoll
und irgendwann hat sich dann einer überlegt, die Protokolle sollten doch öffentlich für
alle einsehbar sein, also nicht, also für alle, nicht öffentlich im Internet, sondern
öffentlich für alle, die in der Firma arbeiten, einsehbar sein, da könnte man so ein bisschen
gucken und dann, nicht so Geheimniskremerei, so, das ist natürlich eine doofe Idee gewesen,
aus mehreren Gründen, auf der einen Seite ist es cool, man kann sehen, was andere so
treiben, mal nachgucken vielleicht, was, haben die schon angefangen mit meiner Sache,
die ich da beauftragt habe, das ist übrigens ein Video, das ist ein Thema, da würde ich
gerne ein Video zu sehen, von, wie heißt das Spiel, der Frankfurter Professor auf YouTube,
so ein Spieltheorie-Video zu sehen, ja, weil der macht gerne, Riek, Riek, da würde ich
gerne ein Video von sehen, weil der macht ja immer Videos zu, so falsch, das eine sagen,
aber falsche Anreize setzen, dass es die Leute nicht machen und zwar, bei uns ist es so,
es gibt Protokolle und die sind jetzt, wurde sich entschieden, Protokolle von Teamrunden
öffentlich zu machen und ich hab halt gemerkt, das setzt halt Anreize dafür, dass die Leute
eben nicht mehr wichtige und brisante Sachen und Informations, ja, wichtige Informationen
in die Protokolle schreiben, beispielsweise, ich hab das erlebt, bei mir, im Team, da gibt
es halt so ein paar Themen, die ziehen sich schon relativ lange hin, sind auch relativ
unbeliebt und jedes Mal, wenn jemand ein Protokoll schreibt und einer was dazu sagt und dann
fragt, soll das auch ins Protokoll, sagt mein Chef, nee, nee, lass das mal aus dem Protokoll
raus, warum, weil wenn irgendjemand dieses Protokoll liest, dann stellt er fest, ah,
blödes Thema, was machen die denn da und dann kommt er zu meinem Chef und fragt nach
und es geht meinem Chef auf den Keks, deswegen kommt das dann nicht ins Protokoll, ah nee,
das müssen wir so nicht ins Protokoll schreiben, was wieder kompletten Sinn dahinter, diese
Protokolle zu erstellen, weil das ja oft mal noch wichtige Informationen sind, wieder
irgendwie so ein bisschen absurd werden lässt, ja, das wird mir einfach, also von der Idee
her gut, aber praktisch hat es genau das Gegenteil bewirkt.
Ich muss immer noch genug arbeiten, glaubst mir, ich arbeite zwar nur 4 Tage und das schon
seit 2011 oder 12 oder 11 oder irgendwie Weile, Weile 4-Tage-Woche, das ist auch das
beste, was ich jedem empfehlen kann, 4-Tage-Woche zu arbeiten,
aber ich arbeite nach wie vor 80%, also kaum arbeiten ist für mich was anderes als 80%,
also 4 Tage arbeiten, also 80% heißt ja im Endeffekt 4 Tage arbeiten, 3 Tage frei, genau,
das kommt ja auch noch dabei, nicht nur Sachen weglassen, sondern dass auch sehr viel Selbstbeweihräucherung
ins Protokoll kommt, was eigentlich jeder in dem Team weiß und was überhaupt keinen
großen Informationsgehalt mehr hat, na gut.
gut luck, have fun 2023 geht jetzt los, easy, ich habe jetzt leider kein Raketen-Emoji,
aber noch nicht mal ansatzweise sowas in der Richtung, aber der Start ist immer holprig.
Tja Leute, ich habe Hunger as fuck, ich bin schon 3 Stunden on, ich habe viel zu viel
geschwätzt wieder, wir haben kaum was geguckt, wir haben 2 Videos geguckt Leute, ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen, wir haben 2 Videos geguckt und ich habe 3 Stunden geschwätzt, wie habe
ich das auf die Reihe gekriegt wieder, du musst 2023 immer noch durchs Bahnhof vierteln, ja
muss ich, muss ich.
Mein neuer Arbeitgeber ist so ungefähr 800 oder sagen wir 1000 Meter, so im Umkreis von
1000 Metern von meinem aktuellen Weg, zockst du generell noch irgendwelche Games, oh ja,
Oldschool MMOs, viel zu viel, ich habe glaube ich, ich habe letztens mal geguckt, ich habe
so viele, also der Server ging online, 12, 20, 12, irgendwie hier so ging der Server
online und ich habe im Durchschnitt glaube ich 7 Stunden am Tag oder so gespielt, viel
zu leise, warum ist das so leise, soll nicht so leise sein, soll lauter sein, testen, testen
ob es jetzt besser ist, ach scheiß drauf, volle Pulle, Wer spielt freiwillig Flip, man,
was kommt als nächstes, Mädchen 2 oder sowas, so Crap wird nicht gespielt hier, Leute ich
gehe jetzt was essen, ich habe Hunger, Kack wait, People fat time, so sieht es aus, du hast
predicted, ich gehe jetzt was essen, ich habe Hunger, bis zum nächsten Mal und dann machen
wir wieder ein bisschen High IQ Technik, bis dann machts gut, C U.